Was, es gibt Werbung? Warum gibt es Werbung? Ich habe keine Werbung. Es könnte aber auch sein, dass mein eigener Stream ist und ich deswegen keine Werbung habe.
Also, ich bin gerade aufgestanden. Ich habe mir gedacht, ich mache jetzt einfach mal Stream an.
Vielleicht wird das jetzt, haben wir letzten Sonntag ja auch schon gemacht.
Vielleicht kriegen wir das ja sogar regelmäßig jetzt sonntags morgens hin.
Ähm, wir gucken jetzt ein paar Videos und ein paar Sachen an und Zeugs an, so irgendwie, keine Ahnung.
Mal gucken, wie lange, bis wir wach sind auf jeden Fall.
Ähm, das erste, was ich heute Morgen gelesen habe, ist auf Heise, wo ich mir gedacht habe, jetzt wollen sie es wissen.
Äh, ich schreibe mal Kasachstan so.
Kasachstan.
Zumindest habe ich heute Morgen gelesen.
Das war das, vielleicht war das gar nicht auf Heise.
Heise vielleicht war es auf Golem.
Zumindest haben sie sich in Kasachstan überlegt.
Ja, hier, ach, Golem war das.
Zumindest haben sie sich in Kasachstan überlegt, dass jetzt alle Internetbenutzer in Kasachstan müssen sich ein SSL-Zertifikat installieren.
Von, ja, von der, wahrscheinlich von der Internetüberwachungsbehörde oder wie auch immer das bei denen heißt.
Dass man quasi jeglichen Verschlüsseln.
Den Traffic-Man-in-the-Middle'n kann, ja.
Was halt irgendwie ziemlich beknackt ist.
Ich bin gerade aufgestanden, Evoli.
Ja, und wenn man, wenn man auf eine Seite geht, die verschlüsselt ist und man hat das Zertifikat nicht installiert, hinterlegt bei sich.
Dann wird man umgeleitet vom Provider auf eine Webseite, wo darsteht, dass man das Zertifikat installieren muss.
Ah, das ist mal ein Big Brain hier.
Ah, ich frage mich, wann sie bei uns auf so Ideen kommen.
So Sachen werden ja immer mehr salonfähig, irgendwie.
Aber dann mache ich halt SSH-Tunnel über, keine Ahnung, Uzbekistan oder keine Ahnung.
Oder SSH-Tunnel über, SSH-Tunnel über indonesisches VPN oder irgendwie sowas.
Was zockst du eigentlich auf Konsole oder PC? Hauptsächlich PC.
Wobei es in letzter Zeit wenig Games gibt, die mir gefallen.
Deswegen spiele ich recht wenig.
Ich habe letzten sogar mal wieder Half-Life 2 installiert.
Einfach so, als ich wusste, was ich spielen soll.
Hast du jemals die Homepage von Stack Overflow gesehen?
Hä?
Ach so, du meinst die Startseite?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, ne.
Ne, glaube ich, habe ich nie gesehen.
Habe ich, glaube ich, nie gesehen.
Die Homepage habe ich, glaube ich, nie gesehen, ne.
Factorio kenne ich, Factorio habe ich schon eine ganze Weile gespielt.
Allerdings.
Gibt es bestimmt mittlerweile schon jede Menge Updates dazu, die ich noch nicht gespielt habe.
Factorio ist nice.
Ja, aber das ist schon hart hier, äh, muss Zertifikate einspielen, dass die Regierung meinen in den Mitteln kann.
Sie gelesen, dass, ähm, irgendeiner hat doch erzählt, dass Fliegen unbedingt teurer werden muss.
Kam mir letztens auch in die News, ne.
Und da ist mir mal wieder aufgefallen, dass ich keine Ahnung habe, also bei so geilen Aussagen immer,
dass ich keine Ahnung habe, dass Fliegen unbedingt teurer werden muss.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie ich wählen soll, äh, nächste.
Ist ja noch ein bisschen hin, ja.
Ich weiß es echt nicht.
Es gibt für mich einfach keinen, den ich irgendwie richtig, den ich wählen kann.
Es gibt irgendwie da immer nur Aussagen, die so schwarz und weiß sind, irgendwie.
Naja, also zumindest, ähm, ist vielleicht schon mal irgendjemand auf die, auf die Idee gekommen,
dass man nicht Fliegen unbedingt teurer machen muss,
sondern man könnte ja auch dafür sorgen, dass es ordentliche Alternativen gibt,
dass die Leute nicht mehr fliegen.
Also, ich meine, ich finde es bescheuert, dass so viele Leute fliegen,
beziehungsweise, dass so viel Umweltverschmutzung passiert, was Flugzeuge und vor allem auch, äh, Dings hier, Schiffe angeht.
Wenn ich mir überlege, ich bestelle ja selbst aus, von, von AliExpress, ne,
was das, was das kostet, also beziehungsweise, was das an, an Zeug ausstößt,
ist, äh, ja auch nicht feierlich, ne.
Aber, warum sagt man nicht einfach, das ist eh was, was ich vermisse irgendwie.
So, so, so.
Da ist so ein Plan dahinter, wie das gemacht werden soll, ne.
Du kannst, also man, also die Noob-Variante ist,
die Noob-Variante ist, wenn man feststellt, die Leute fahren zu viel mit dem Auto und, und, ähm,
die Leute fliegen zu viel mit dem Flugzeug,
die Noob-Variante ist dann zu sagen, ah ja, gut, dann müssen wir halt verbieten, mit dem Auto zu fahren und das Fliegen so teuer machen,
da es keiner mehr fliegen kann.
Das ist die Noob-Variante.
Die eigentlich viel sinnvollere Variante.
Weil ich meine, die Leute müssen sich irgendwie von A nach B bewegen können.
Die eigentlich sinnvollere Variante wäre ja, man versucht irgendwie Alternativen zu schaffen, so mit, mit nem Plan.
Dahinter, ja ich weiß, Plan, das ist nicht so, ist nicht so beliebt irgendwie.
Ähm, aber mit nem Plan dahinter, dass man sagt, okay, wir haben uns jetzt vorgestellt, äh, Nahverkehr für die nächsten 15 Jahre, nen Plan.
Und nicht nur nen Plan, wo's heißt, in 15 Jahren wollen wir das und das machen, sondern, oder sagen wir 20 Jahren,
Plan, wo man sagen kann, okay, die nächsten
zwei Jahre passiert das, die nächsten zwei Jahre passiert
das, die nächsten zwei, dass man auch zwischendurch
nachguckt, wie das denn aussieht. Nicht
wie unsere
Internet-Ausbau-
Pläne, die wir immer haben, so
nach dem Motto, bis 2020,
das und das für alle. Und
dann ist es Mitte 2020 und dann
kommt dann, oh, oh Mist,
das haben wir gar nicht geschafft.
Damit konnte keiner rechnen,
dass wir das nicht schaffen. Wir haben bisher
alle unsere Breitbandziele erreicht. Wie
konnte man darauf kommen, dass wir es nicht schaffen, bis
2000, das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Du bräuchtest
einen ordentlichen Plan,
wie das gemacht werden soll.
Auch einen Plan, wo man die Umsetzung irgendwie
nachvollziehen kann. Einen Plan, der öffentlich ist,
wo man irgendwie erkennt,
okay, da hat sich einer Gedanken
gemacht und das ist
was, womit ich irgendwie letztendlich leben kann.
Ich finde es vollkommen okay und auch
notwendig, dass man
das alles ein bisschen einschränkt.
Allerdings am besten ist das natürlich, wenn man
dann auch Alternativen bietet, die die Leute
verwenden können.
Was hat es für einen Sinn, wenn alles,
wenn du sagst, wir verbieten das, wir machen
das andere teurer, aber wir haben keine Alternativen.
Ja, was bleibt den Leuten denn anders übrig?
Also meiner Ansicht nach,
ja, müsste das Ziel sein, dass du
innerhalb von Deutschland dich zumindest
ohne Probleme von einer
Stadt zur anderen Stadt bewegen kannst
mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln.
Und halt auch in
angemessenem Zeitrahmen, ja.
Also sprich, dass ich beispielsweise von
na gut, von Frankfurt
nach Köln, das ist jetzt ein doofes Beispiel, weil in Frankfurt
Köln ist es ziemlich easy,
dass ich jetzt vielleicht schon in einem bisschen kleineren Stadt drumherum
keine Ahnung, alle 10 Minuten nach Frankfurt komme,
wenn ich dann in Frankfurt am Südbahnhof bin,
dass ich dann weiterfahren kann mit irgendwas
anderem. In Frankfurt selbst ist das ja kein
Problem, aber das wird halt viel mehr ausgebaut.
Sag mal, aktuell ist es so, da hast
du Strecken, die willst du fahren,
da fahren zwei Züge am Tag
oder lass mal fünf Züge
am Tag sein oder teilweise Züge mit zwei Stunden
Unterschied. Es ist voll für
den Arsch. Wie kann man ernsthaft
den Leuten
erzählen, die
da wohnen, so nach dem Motto,
ja ne, ihr dürft mit dem Auto nicht mehr nach Frankfurt fahren.
Das ist doch total hängen geblieben.
Vor allem
überzeugst du letztendlich ja auch keinen
mit solchen Sachen.
Die Leute überzeugst
du damit, nicht mit
du verbietest alles. Das kann man
machen, das kann man machen, wenn es Alternativen
gibt. Du überzeugst ja die Leute nicht
damit, wenn du die ganzen Sachen
verbietest oder noch besser
den Leuten sagst, ich will noch, ne, ne, ja, drüber reden,
ist auch ganz böse,
sondern indem du
irgendwelche Alternativen
zumindest in Aussicht stellst,
wo die Leute dann sagen können,
okay, das ist gut, damit kann ich leben, da brauche ich
das andere ja gar nicht mehr.
Und sowas.
Es ist irgendwie,
ich vermisse generell bei
vielen Sachen so den Plan dahinter
einfach. Ich glaube,
es ist unstrittig,
dass wir Maßnahmen zum Umweltschutz
brauchen. Aber irgendwie außer
irgendwelche dollen Aussagen so, ja, das
müssen wir jetzt sofort abschalten und das müssen wir machen.
So einen Plan dahinter
irgendwie oder auch was
Breitbahnausbau, Internet angeht
oder was Infrastrukturausbau, Nahverkehr,
Bahn angeht, irgendwie vermisse ich
so den langfristigen
Plan dahinter einfach.
Und wie gesagt,
kein Plan, der irgendwie sagt, in 30
Jahren wollen wir das haben, weil
who cares, was in 30 Jahren ist,
das sagt man dann einfach so.
Nee, nee, das muss ein Plan sein, wo drinnen steht,
ganz genau, wie es ablaufen soll, dass man auch
kontrollieren kann, wie es aussieht. Aber das kriegen sie.
Das
funktioniert irgendwie nicht.
Und heute machen wir es so, heute ist
alles mehr oder weniger schwarz und weiß.
Wenn du was sagst,
was quasi
gerade nicht so
offensichtlicher
Konsens ist oder vorgeschriebener
Konsens, da wirst du quasi fast
gesellschaftlich, wie kann man sagen,
gesteinigt, so nach dem, wie kann man das denn
sagen, das geht ja gar nicht.
Und ich glaube
nicht, dass es förderlich ist,
wenn man Diskussionen über
Sachen, die die Leute bewegt, unterbindet,
anstatt darüber zu diskutieren.
Das hat auch noch nie irgendwie
funktioniert. Und übrigens Leute, ich habe gestern
Apollo 11 im Kino geguckt.
Das ist kein Film, das ist
eine Dokumentation
mit, also
ich würde mal sagen, zu 95%
manche Sachen waren, glaube ich, nicht Originalfilmaufnahmen,
aber zu 95%
aus, also das da,
das hier,
Dokumentation, das ist 1,5 Stunden,
1 Stunde 33 oder so,
steht, glaube ich, drauf, der Laufzeit.
Und, ähm,
also, mir sind
ein paar Sachen aufgefallen, als ich das gesehen habe.
Erstens
habe ich ja gestern noch auf Twitter geschrieben,
dass die Astronauten in der Rakete
beim Start
einen niedrigeren Puls,
hatten, als ich, wenn ich auf dem Klo sitze,
wo ich mir schon mal gedacht habe,
fuck, also ein 88er Puls,
so, ja, also, unter mir
explodieren gerade irgendwie zig Tonnen
von, äh,
was ist das, ähm, flüssig
Treibstoff,
was auch immer, ähm,
keine Ahnung, was ich das zusammensetze,
ähm, ja, unter mir explodieren gerade
tonnenweise irgendwelche Sachen, aber
Puls von 88.
Easy. Überhaupt kein Problem.
Easy.
Okay, also, wahrscheinlich habe ich einen höheren Puls,
wenn ich auf dem Klo sitze, als der Typ,
wenn er in der Rakete sitzt und die Rakete startet, gerade.
Ja, wieso spoilerst du?
Ja, scheiße, ne?
Spoiler, weil das Sache, die 50 Jahre her ist.
Ähm, zumindest,
das ist so die Sache, wo ich mir gedacht habe,
das war schon nicht schlecht, aber was mir dabei auch noch
aufgefallen ist,
ähm,
und übrigens, ich kann,
ich kann, ich kann es jedem empfehlen, sich anzugucken,
ähm,
ist halt,
es ist halt kein, kein
Film in dem Sinne. Das ist halt wirklich,
wirklich eine Doku, aber die ist ziemlich gut geschnitten
und hat auch kaum Längen, was du bei
anderen Dokus oftmals hast.
Ja, es geht, es geht eigentlich Schlag auf Schlag
und, ähm,
im Prinzip hast du, hast du auch kaum,
kaum Erzähler in dem Sinne,
du hast eigentlich nur Funkverkehr.
Funkverkehr und ein bisschen,
ein bisschen, äh, drumherum, äh,
äh,
drumherum Gerede von dem, von dem,
dem Missions-Commander-Typ.
Was übrigens ganz schrecklich war,
waren die Untertitel.
Also, ich, ich, ich konnte,
ich hätte jedes Mal ausflippen können,
äh, der, der Film ist im Original Ton,
ja, allerdings mit riesengroßen Untertiteln,
was übelst der Fail ist, und wenn sie dann
Engine mit Maschine übersetzen, habe ich schon immer,
die, die haben nicht irgendwie gesagt, die haben teilweise gesagt,
Engine ist Maschine, und ich meine,
das ist eine, das ist eine Rakete.
Seit wann hat, seit wann ist eine Engine
bei einer Rakete eine Maschine?
Also, wer übersetzt das denn mit Maschine?
Äh, wer hat das, wer hat das übersetzt?
Das ist ein Triebwerk, in dem Fall,
aber keine Maschine.
Egal, aber die Untertitel waren teilweise echt grausam.
Aber der Film ist zum Glück im Original Ton.
Äh, es wirkte, es wirkte wirklich ein bisschen
wie, wie, wie Google Translate, äh,
also da weiß ich auch nicht, was los ist.
Zumindest kann man auf jeden Fall, kann man
auf jeden Fall empfehlen, man muss es auch nicht im Kino
gucken, ich meine, es wirkt schon cool, und was mir
aufgefallen ist noch, ey, erstens,
ähm,
wie gut die Filmaufnahmen
ausgesehen haben,
ich meine, das sind, das sind, das ist
50 Jahre her, wo sie den Kram aufgenommen
haben, ne, und
die Filmaufnahmen sahen richtig gut aus.
Sogar die
Filmaufnahmen aus, aus diesem komischen
Landemodul sahen halbwegs gut aus.
Die hatten eine Kamera
dabei, mit einem FPS,
aber von der Auflösung
her war das echt nice,
das, das sah, das, das könnte glatt
als 1080p-Video durchgehen, wenn du das
heute dir anguckst.
Eine FPS-Kamera.
Ah, ja, Studio-Kamera, das ist genau.
Ähm,
und,
also da war ich echt, da war ich
echt überrascht, wie gut die, wie gut die Filmaufnahmen
ausgesehen haben, natürlich nicht von
allem, ja, wenn du da irgendwie eine Kamera
an, an, an, an irgendwie einem Triebwerk
hängen hattest, das hat schon ganz schön gewackelt und sah nicht
gut aus, aber ey, das waren immerhin Originalaufnahmen.
Und was mich auch
echt überrascht hat, ist,
wie gut die
Audioaufnahmen waren.
Ich mein, man muss sich mal überlegen,
wie weit ist der Mond weg von der Erde?
300.000 Kilometer
oder so?
Ja, äh, 400.000 Kilometer?
So, und
die Audioaufnahmen,
die klangen teilweise,
ich weiß, bisschen übertrieben, ich weiß,
die klangen teilweise besser wie aktuelle
VoIP-Gespräche.
Wir haben, wir haben auf der Arbeit,
ja, das große Vergnügen, mit
Skype for Business arbeiten zu dürfen.
Und, ähm,
wir haben auch so ein paar Microsoft
äh, Surface Hubs.
Das sind so große, große
Fernsehdinger, wo man mit, mit einem riesen
Touchscreen und so, die sind übelst, übelst teuer.
Gucken, was so ein Ding
eigentlich kostet, was weiß ich, 30k oder sowas.
Ähm,
nä, nä, nä, nä.
Kann man, kann man so irgendwie gar nicht kaufen.
Das sind irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, 70 Zoll
Bildschirme mit Touchscreen. Das ist übelst nice.
Eigentlich. Zumindest,
was man machen kann, man kann
über Skype dann eine Telefonkonferenz
oder eine Audiokonferenz
kann man, kann man einladen.
Und was ganz besonders abartig ist, ist,
wenn du externe Leute,
die nicht im gleichen Skype for Business
sind,
einlädst dazu. Das läuft dann folgendermaßen.
Die kriegen per Mail
eine Nachricht, dass sie jetzt
eingeladen sind zu einer Skype for Business
Konferenz. Und
da drinnen ist ein Link,
den klickst du an
und dann kriegst du einen Secret
Code. Mit diesem Secret
Code musst du dann per Telefon
bei so einem, bei so einem
Telefondienst anrufen,
gibst den Secret Code, den
Konferenzcode ein
und dann wirst du quasi über diesen Anbieter
in die Konferenz zugeschaltet.
So, der Witz ist natürlich, dass
der externe Anbieter, der dann anruft und bei uns
intern an der Telefonkonferenz teilnehmen will,
selbst ja auch irgendein komisches VoIP-System
hat. Leute, ich sag euch,
die Qualität von diesen
Gesprächen ist um ein Vielfaches
schlechter, als die Kommunikation
mit Apollo 11 400.000
Kilometer entfernt.
Apollo 11 hast du wenigstens alles verstanden, was
die Leute gesagt haben, wenn man sich Mühe gegeben hat.
Bei der Skype-Konferenz
über drei VoIP-Systeme drüber,
über zigmal Format gewandelt,
Kompression, dann irgendwie noch digital-analog,
analog-digital,
was auch immer alles umgewandelt
zwischendurch. Die Qualität ist
heute bei so einer Telefonkonferenz, obwohl die
in Frankfurt sitzen, schlechter,
als die mit den Leuten auf dem Mond
telefoniert haben, kommuniziert
haben. Voller Witz eigentlich, ne?
Naja, und
was mir noch aufgefallen ist dabei,
als ich das geguckt
hab, ähm,
sag mal so,
vor allem in Europa
stehen wir ja grad
so ein bisschen vor der Herausforderung,
wie wir Leute integrieren.
In Deutschland natürlich. Auch in Schweden ist es ja
wohl aktuell ganz besonders schlimm.
Und eine Sache ist mir dabei
aufgefallen, ähm,
dass es eigentlich
überhaupt nicht
drum geht,
oder zumindest glaube ich
das, also zumindest kommt mir das
irgendwie schlüssig vor, nachdem ich das geguckt hab,
dass es gar nicht so sehr drum geht,
ähm,
den Leuten irgendwas aufzuzwingen,
also in
beide Richtungen, so nachdem
im Motto, du musst dich jetzt hier anpassen
und du musst besonders tolerant sein und du musst
das und du musst dich hier einschränken und das kannst du
nicht sagen, sondern ich glaube,
dass was wirklich die Leute
sag mal so, vereint,
oder was wirklich
die Leute vereinen kann,
ist, wenn sie gemeinsame Ziele
haben. Und dann ist es doch im Prinzip
scheißegal,
für was das der, was
der persönliche Antrieb eines jeden
ist, der da mitmacht, warum er das macht,
das gemeinsame Ziel
haben sie trotzdem alle.
Also nachdem ich das geguckt hab, glaube ich echt,
man vereint Leute nicht damit, dass man es ihnen aufzwängt,
sondern dass, dass man,
dass man es schafft, dass, dass quasi
die unterschiedlichsten Leute
ein gemeinsames Ziel
und nennen wir es mal gemeinsame Visionen haben.
Und wenn man das hinkriegt,
dann ziehen auch ganz viele Leute an
einem Strang. Ich glaube, das
äh, haben wir noch nicht geschafft.
Gut, ich meine, wir können jetzt nicht sagen, hallo Leute,
wir bauen jetzt alle eine Rakete zusammen, aber
so vom Ansatz her, wisst ihr was ich meine?
Achso, und was ich auch verstehen kann,
ist, warum, wenn man das, wenn man
das geguckt hat, warum man,
warum man damals
gedacht hat, dass wir quasi
2019 mal mindestens irgendwie auf dem
Mars oder sonst wo rumhüpfen,
ähm,
ja, und heute machen wir, äh,
Skype for Business VoIP Calls,
hehehe, Patrick, tja,
es sind nicht nur Einser, es sind auch Urls,
jaja, weiß nicht, weil ich mir das
das ist halt so, es ist gleich wie mit Eins.
Ahem.
Was auch richtig, richtig cool zu sehen
war,
dass, ähm, was man, also, wenn man, wenn man sich
den Film angeguckt hat, dass an ganz
vielen, äh, Stellen im Kommunikations,
ähm, Dings, da,
Center, ähm,
und überall, dass überall auch Frauen dabei gewesen sind.
Weil heute teilweise so getan
wird, als ist, sind in solchen Berufen, als
als gibt's da quasi überhaupt keine Frauen oder so.
Ey, es gab damals Frauen, und ich bin mir sicher, die haben
genauso dazu beigetragen, dass das funktioniert hat.
Das, das, das sollte man
ja nicht unter den Teppich kehren.
Und das hat damals sogar ganz ohne, äh,
Feminismus und, und, äh,
alle Männer sind scheiße funktioniert.
Sachen
gibt's, äh.
Äh, kurz eine Frage, du sagst
Windows, vor allem in der KVM
am besten mit einer Grafikkarte am Haus, damit das
ordentlich läuft, was, was? Nein, sag ich
nicht. Also, eben wohl, wenn man
das gesehen hat, wird man sehen, dass so
ziemlich nichts an
dieser ganzen Mission von einer Person
gemacht wurde. Das waren
hunderte Leute dran, in allen möglichen Sachen.
Und du hast auch gesehen, da war
keiner irgendwie mit halber Arschbacke dabei,
die haben sich alle halb in die Hose
geschissen, wenn sie mal 15 Sekunden lang nix
gehört haben. Aber nochmal zu dem, was,
was, äh, Sharks Development geschrieben
hat, wie kommst du da drauf? Du sagst Windows
vor allem in der KVM am besten in der
Grafikkarte vom Haus. Hä,
nee, warum? Einfach
Windows...
Moment, warte mal.
Nee, also in, in
in KVM läuft, laufen Windows
VMs auch ohne Probleme, ist überhaupt kein Ding.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Ähm...
Und wenn du eine Grafikkarte
durchreichst an die VM, wird's sogar
komplizierter, weil du dann
einen extra, einen extra Monitor
brauchst an dem Grafikkarte, an der Ausgang von der
Grafikkarte. Also würde ich,
würde keine extra Grafikkarte durchreichen.
Also wenn ich Windows unter
Linux verwenden müsste,
würde ich mir überlegen, ob ich nicht, also wenn's zu
Desktop-Zwecken ist, ob ich nicht einfach Virtualbox
nehme, weil damit funktioniert das wahrscheinlich besser.
Ähm...
Und...
Ansonsten einfach KVM, Windows installieren,
Tools installieren. Aber rein
auf dem Desktop Windows virtualisiere unter Linux
würde ich sagen, ist tatsächlich Virtualbox
sogar noch einen Ticken besser.
Ja, so, und jetzt machen wir das, was wir das letzte
Mal auch gemacht haben, nachdem ich mich jetzt ja ewig
dran ausgelassen hab. Ähm...
Zu irgendwelchen
gesellschaftlichen Problemen, die wir haben. Gibt's da
irgendwelche Fragen, die ich, die ich übersehen
hab?
Äh, Timbo sagt,
was ich krass finde, dass die
mit Taschenrechnerleistung losgeflogen sind.
Jaja, die sind vor allem, die sind,
die sind nicht nur mit Taschenrechnerleistung
losgeflogen, die sind, die sind auch
teilweise einfach mal manuell losgeflogen.
Die hatten auf dem Fenster
aufgemalt so nen, so nen,
das sah aus ein bisschen wie
Millimeterpapier, und
danach sind die, sind die Sachen angeflogen.
Nach, nach quasi aufgemalten
Einheiten auf dem Fenster.
Ja, also da mussten auch schon Leute
drin sitzen, die halbwegs wissen, was sie machen.
Sonst würde das nicht funktionieren.
Das war schon nice,
sich anzugucken. Also wie gesagt,
die Doku kann ich echt empfehlen, das ist,
das ist super zusammengeschnitten.
Es ist qualitativ ziemlich
gut von den Aufnahmen her, für das, dass das uralt
ist eigentlich, ne? Aus heutigen Gesichtspunkten.
Ja, und wenn's geht, guckt's euch ohne Untertitel an,
weil die sind eigentlich, die sind, die sind nur im Weg.
Die sind scheiße übersetzt. Man braucht da,
man braucht wirklich auch, selbst wenn man richtig schlecht
Englisch kann oder gar kein Englisch kann,
ähm, man braucht
den Ton, also man braucht das
Commentary gar nicht großartig dabei.
Es reicht schon eigentlich, wenn man sich das anguckt.
So, und jetzt
gucken wir mal, ich hab hier ne Playlist auf Youtube,
aber um anderen,
äh, keine Playlist, keine Playlist auf Youtube,
eine Playlist von Youtube,
also die ich zusammen
gebastelt hab. Ich hab, ich, ich guck
ja immer, wenn ich abends, wenn ich, äh, wenn ich ins Bett gehe,
guck ich auch ein bisschen auf dem Tablet, ein bisschen,
bisschen Videos oder Streams oder sowas zum Einpennen.
Und ich speichere mir einfach immer alle
möglichen Videos, die irgendwie interessant klingen und da hab ich
jetzt mal ein paar rauskopiert. Und wir gucken uns
das Ganze an. Übrigens, hab ich gelesen,
das müssen wir uns angucken. Habt ihr schon den Witcher 3
Trailer gesehen?
Ich hab heut Morgen gelesen, es gibt nen Witcher 3 Trailer.
Ne, nicht nen Witcher 3 Trailer,
vergiss es, nen Witcher-Serie-Trailer.
Alter, ihr Big Brain,
es ist noch früh.
Witcher-Serie-Trailer, nicht Witcher 3 Trailer.
Witcher
Trailer, so rum.
Netflix,
genau, den wollte ich nämlich
auch noch gucken.
Mit Superman, genau.
Official Teaser,
zwei Minuten.
German, German Trailer.
Lass uns mal
den, Netflix, vor einem Tag,
ja, das wird er sein. Okay, Moment,
Musik aus, müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Bin ich echt gespannt drauf. Könnt ihr
euch noch an den Shitstorm erinnern?
Wo sie, wo sie gesagt haben,
die sollte ne Asiatin werden?
Wie sie sich da alle aufgeregt haben, ey.
Und Yennefer ist, ist,
sollte, sollte jemand aus Indien spielen,
oder irgendwie sowas. Ich weiß nicht, was da rausgekommen ist,
aus der ganzen Sache. Das einzige, was ich weiß,
ist, dass Superman, äh, Geralt
spielt. So, gucken wir mal.
Das ist Serie, oder?
…
Du hast das, was es braucht.
Wir sind hier.
Wir müssen versuchen, die Kirche.
Du kannst die Streitigkeit nicht ausreißen,
nur weil du davon gefreut bist.
Es kommt.
Find Guild of Revue.
Ich kann das ohne dich nicht machen.
Egal, was du wählst.
Du wirst blöd auskommen.
CGI-Enhanced-Hintergründe.
Weil spätestens seit Herr der Ringe
wird ja so eine Schlacht nicht mehr mit 50.000 Leuten gemacht.
Sondern halt mit, keine Ahnung, 20 oder so.
Hat irgendwie nicht viel mit Wirtschaft...
Keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich meine, sie haben ja gesagt,
dass sich das Ganze nach den Büchern richtet
und wohl auch quasi ab dem Erstbuch anfängt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich habe das nicht gelesen.
Ich kann das überhaupt nicht...
einschätzen, ob das was mit Witcher zu tun hat oder nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Also für mich sieht das hier schon sehr Witcher-Style aus.
Warum die in Fantasy-Filmen allerdings immer
irgendwelche komischen Lederdinger anhaben müssen,
das verstehe ich tatsächlich nicht.
Keiner, der noch irgendwie bei Verstand ist
und vor allem keiner,
der gegen irgendwelche gefährlichen Monsterdinger kämpfen muss,
würde sich irgendwie hautengen Lederkram anziehen.
Wozu?
Er ist ein Hexer, da muss ich hautenges Lederzeug anziehen.
Schon klar.
Ja, ich glaube mal, dass du dich da drin gar nicht mal gut bewegen kannst.
Vor allem biete das null Schutz gegen irgendwas.
Triff dich das Monster einmal, bam.
Kettenrüstung stört überhaupt nicht.
Ich hatte mal bei uns...
Also, jetzt ist es ewig, ewig, ja.
Wer konnte mal bei uns eine Kettenrüstung anziehen
auf so einem Mittelaltermarkt?
Hatte ich mal eine Kettenrüstung an?
Das merkst du kaum.
Eine Kettenhemd merkst du kaum.
Das juckt überhaupt nicht.
Ich hatte mal auf so einem Mittelaltermarkt,
hatte ich mal eine Kettenrüstung an
und du merkst das kaum, dass du ein Kettenhemd anhast.
Ich meine, vielleicht hat er ja ein Kettenhemd drunter.
Okay, ja, kann ja sein, kann ja sein.
Ich finde, es sieht schon...
Und eins muss ich sagen,
ich finde schon, wo hat man es denn gesehen?
Irgendwo saß er doch auf dem Bett
und hat irgendwie so Witcher-mäßig geguckt.
Weiß nicht wo.
Ich fand es da schon,
ich meine, das sieht...
Ich habe auch erst gedacht,
okay, er sieht irgendwie immer noch aus wie Superman,
aber ich finde, das trifft es doch echt ganz gut.
Also ich finde das echt nicht übel.
Er hat kein Kettenhemd drunter.
Er hat ein Kettenhemd drunter, wird man das sehen.
Das ist einfach YOLO, der YOLO-Witcher-Style.
Wer braucht, wer braucht,
wer braucht schon Kettenhemd
und wer braucht schon irgendwie Rüstung?
Das ist jetzt overrated.
Ja.
Und ich finde, das sieht schon ziemlich cool aus,
wie sie das gemacht haben.
Ich meine, der hat auch schon ordentlich Muckis hier.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob Gerald in den Büchern auch so ein muskulöser Klotz ist.
Aber ich finde, es sieht schon nicht schlecht aus.
Also ich fand den Trailer nicht schlecht.
Wann kommt denn das Ganze raus?
Und ganz ehrlich, die Verteilung von Likes zu Dislikes
fällt eindeutig zugegeben,
zugunsten von Netflix aus,
weil die Hardcore-Fans
sowohl von Büchern als auch Spielen
sind immer enttäuscht.
Du kannst es im Prinzip keinem so richtig recht machen
mit einer
Serien- oder Filmumsetzung.
Das heißt, die Likes zu Dislikes,
da haben auch sehr viele Hardcore-Fans geliked.
Also das
für so eine bekannte
Marke im Endeffekt
ist dieses Like-Dislike-Verhältnis
spricht eindeutig für Netflix.
Hallo? Wo sind die Comments?
Okay, das Comment ist schon lustig.
Ja, aber
die Trailer haben ja oftmals eine merkwürdige
Musik, wo man sich denkt, das hat mit dem eigentlichen
wenig zu tun. Was mich echt
enttäuscht hat, was Trailer und Musik ist,
der...
Könnt ihr euch noch an den
Breath of the Wild Trailer erinnern?
Und zwar an diesen Part.
Ich zeig nur den Part, den ich meine.
Genau, ab hier.
Ab hier.
Du denkst dir, pass mal jetzt.
Also ab jetzt.
Das war...
Das ist einer der geilsten Trailer,
den Nintendo je gemacht hat, ne?
Und wisst ihr, was das Problem ist?
Dass die Musik auch übelst geil klingt
und die Musik,
den Breath of the Wild, ist im Vergleich zum Trailer
total...
Ich will nicht sagen totaler Crap, aber
irgendwie nicht vorhanden
im Vergleich zum Trailer.
Ich war übelst gehypt, als ich den Trailer gesehen hab.
Vor allem, wo es diese...
Wo die Fee aus dem...
Aus dem See rauskommt, ja?
Die Musik passt übelst geil.
Und wenn sie dann noch
das...
Das Overworld
Main Theme einspielt, das war richtig geil.
Ich hab mir gedacht, Alter,
endlich mal
nen Orchester Soundtrack,
nen richtig geiler Zelda Soundtrack
und dann kommt...
Und dann kommt...
Dann kommt das hier.
Es ist nicht schlecht.
Es passt irgendwie auch zu dem Game.
Sie haben ja gesagt, ähm...
Sie haben ja gesagt, sie machen...
Sie haben das so gemacht, weil sie wollen,
dass die Welt im Vordergrund steht und sowas.
Aber ich bin der Ansicht,
so gut Breath of the Wild an sich war von...
Zumindest von der Spielwelt her und von dem,
was du machen konntest,
ich bin immer noch der Ansicht, irgendwie hat dem Spiel...
Hätte dem Spiel
ein bisschen mehr Story nicht geschadet.
Ich mein, Breath of the Wild
hat im Endeffekt keine Story.
Das hat die letzten 10 Minuten ein bisschen Story,
aber die ist nicht wirklich da.
Und das...
Den Teil von der Story, die man zwischendurch sieht,
ist total belanglos.
Also...
Näh.
Also ich hätt's...
Ich hätt's viel cooler gefinde...
gefunden, man hätte...
Es wäre mehr Musik in dem Style gewesen.
Und zumindest...
Ey, ich mein, man...
Ich mein...
Das ist einfach übelst epische Zelda-Musik, ja?
Gut, wenn Zelda jetzt da...
Dann nicht.
Aber das ist übelst nice.
Und die...
Die Trailer-Musik ist besser,
als die ganze Musik im fertigen Spiel.
Das ist...
Übelst...
Wirechamp, äh...
Nachdem ich den Trailer geguckt hab,
hab ich mir schon gedacht,
Alter, du musst dir wahrscheinlich noch den Soundtrack holen,
bevor du dir das Spiel holst, ne?
Aber war dann halt nicht so.
Das Beste...
Beste, ähm...
Beste Zelda-Musik ist immer noch...
Ist immer noch das...
Das ist immer noch beste...
Beste...
Beste Zelda-Musik.
Ach was, Song of Storms.
Beste.
Dark Overworld.
Das kannst...
Das kannst du dir Stunden anhören,
wenn du da rumgelaufen bist
und nicht wusstest, wo du hin musst.
Beste.
Sieht nicht aus wie das Master-Share,
das sieht...
Wie das ausschaut.
Aber nicht wie das Master-Share.
Bestes Overworld-Theme hier.
Allerdings...
Allerdings muss man sagen, ähm...
Die haben auch andere sehr geile Sachen.
Äh, ähm...
Ending.
Ja.
Ähm...
Skyward Sword war ja nicht so beliebt, ne?
Aber Skyward Sword hat einen richtig guten Soundtrack.
Ich mein, stellt euch das mal in Breath of the Wild vor,
das wär doch was gewesen.
Ich mein, es passt...
Okay, man muss sagen,
es passt zu Skyward Sword auch deutlich besser,
als zu Breath of the Wild.
Aber trotzdem,
ich fand...
Die Musik in Breath of the Wild jetzt, äh...
Moment.
Ich will...
Ich will keine...
dummen Zwiebeln kaufen.
Äh...
Ist ein bisschen hinter dem zurückgeblieben,
was ich mir gewünscht hätte.
Es hat seine Gründe,
dass sie es so gemacht haben.
Okay.
Aber ich hätt mir das...
Ich hätt's mir irgendwie anders gewünscht.
Aber man kriegt halt nicht immer,
was man haben will, ne?
Okay, wir wollten uns eigentlich angucken.
Das wollte ich mir eigentlich angucken.
Was haben wir vor USB benutzt?
Das hab ich heute Morgen auf dem Tablet angefangen zu gucken,
die ersten paar Minuten.
Hab ich mir gedacht,
äh...
Ich guck's nachher im Rechner weiter.
Breath of the Wild.
Blumenzwiebel.
Breath of the Blumenzwiebel.
Ja.
Ich...
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum.
Warum hab ich denn hier...
Warum hab ich hier Dings drinne?
Green Brokers Limited.
Blumenzwiebel.
Sechs verschiedene Frühlingsblumen besorgen.
Weil...
Okay.
Was haben wir vor USB benutzt?
Na, was...
Was fällt mir denn da ein?
Was haben wir vor USB benutzt?
Wir haben...
Vor USB haben wir benutzt...
Serielle Schnittstelle.
Also...
Serial Port.
Parallel Port.
Joystick Port.
Falls das noch überhaupt irgendjemand kennt.
Joystick.
Ähm...
Was dann oftmals irgendwie an der Soundkarte als Gaming Port oder so dran war.
PS2.
PS2 haben wir noch verwendet.
Diesen DIN-Stecker.
Kennt den noch jemand?
Den da.
Den fetten.
IDE.
Ja, wobei IDE anstatt USB...
Ne, ähm...
Es geht ja um was, was wir anstatt USB verwenden.
Aber so für externe Geräte.
Kennt diesen hässlichen DIN-Stecker noch jemand?
Das war noch...
Das war noch vor PS2 hatte man diese Dinger.
Und dann gab's dann so tolle Sachen wie ein PS2 auf DIN-Stecker Adapter.
Mr.
Harthorst.
Ach du Scheiß.
Haha.
Nice.
Ja, wenn man noch Rechner auf der Arbeit hat mit DIN-Steckern, dann weiß man, was
man da vor sich hat.
Okay, ähm...
Guck mal.
Also, was haben wir vorher benutzt?
We practically connect everything by USB these days.
Keyboards.
Mice.
Speakers.
Keyboards.
Ja.
Da steht mal alles.
Ditschen lauter, okay.
Ah.
Shahahahaha.
Das ist ja geil.
Die meisten davon gibt's nicht.
RIP, RIP, also ich weiß nicht, ob es nicht nur Überreste davon gibt, aber im Endeffekt, ähm, RIP, RIP, gibt's noch, gibt's noch, gibt's noch, RIP, RIP, ja, genau, hab ich doch gesagt, äh, gut, ihr müsst dazu sagen, ich hab das Video am Anfang schon gesehen vorher, äh, Serial Parallel Joystick PS2, genau, nicht IBM RIP, die anderen IBM gibt's noch.
Das war die Seite, die man früher an Drucker angeschlossen hat, ne, gibt's noch, keine Ahnung, hab ich lange nichts davon gehört, das hat man früher an Drucker angeschlossen, diese Seite.
Verkauft im August 1981 wurde der IBM Personal Computer von vielen off-the-shelf-OEM-Parten versammelt, mit einem customes BIOS, aber mit dem Rest, das von den meisten externen Manufakturen hergestellt wurde.
Um das Keyboard zu verbinden, wurde ein 5-Pin-E-Symbol ausgewählt, eine Verbindung, die in den frühen 1970ern in der Computing-Welt etwas standardisiert wurde, von dem Deutsches Institut für Normung.
Deutsches Institut für Normung.
Diese Verbindung war ruckartig, bietet große Schadenswerte,
Das war noch pre-Floppy-Disk.
IBM ist doch jetzt Lenovo.
Ne, ne, ne, das sind zwei unterschiedliche Läden.
Allerdings hat IBM Notebooks und Server-Hardware zum größten Teil an Lenovo verkauft.
Das meint Peripherals such as the mouse, printer, modem or even the monitor needed to be connected through expansion cards.
And these expansion cards plugged into 8-bit expansion slots on the motherboard.
Which would go on to be called the industry-standard architecture or ISA slots.
ISA-Slots, ja.
This name was adopted because the IBM PC spawned many clones.
After all, once the BIOS was reverse-engineered or copied through observation, the other components could be bought from external parties.
And soon the IBM PC-compatible market was born and awash.
Ich meine, du konntest das Zeug damals theoretisch sogar noch ablöten, wenn man sich das anguckt.
Ich meine, hat keiner so wirklich gemacht.
Das sind auch ein paar ganz Hardcore-Leute.
Aber du hast sogar noch die einzelnen Leiterbahnen erkannt, ne?
Heute hast du irgendwie so einen, so einen, was weiß ich, 95 Schichten PCB oder sowas.
PCB.
Ohne, da kennst du nichts mehr.
Und so wurde der IBM PC-kompatible Markt geboren und mit Maschinen erwischt.
Das IBM PC-Modell würde bald genug in die stärkere AT-Maschine entwickeln.
Mit den Klonen natürlich, folgendes.
Aber über all diese Maschinen würde man typisch finden,
eine Videokarte, um deinen Monitor einzuschalten,
eine Serienkarte, die eine oder zwei Serienkarten oder Kommunikationen bietet,
weißt du, RS-232-Porten,
und eine Parallelkarte, obwohl diese oft mit der Serienkarte kombiniert wurde.
Die originalen IBM-Maschinen hatten ein bisschen andere Verbindungen,
aber das ist das typische Setup, das das IBM-PC in Zukunft entwickeln würde.
Also, wir haben die Basis-Kette, aber was ist mit allem anderes?
Na, lasst uns mit der Maus anfangen.
Du könntest das mit einer Serienkarte verbinden.
Ey, wie oft habt ihr fast den Port rausgerissen, weil ihr an diesem Kabel hängen geblieben seid?
Na gut, wahrscheinlich nicht so viele, weil wahrscheinlich nicht so viele den Kram hatten, aber, ähm,
die Stecker, ich hab die nie angeschraubt.
Ich hab die nie angeschraubt, weil ich sonst immer halb den Port rausgerissen hab, wenn ich hängen geblieben bin.
Dein Computer identifiziert diese als Com-Ports,
und normalerweise würde deine Maus eine 9-Pin-Serienkarte haben.
Also, drück sie ein, installiere einen Maus-Driver,
und du hast einen magischen,
On-Screen-Cursor,
für Programme, die damit kompatibel sind.
Wenn du keinen 9-Pin-Serienport hättest,
könntest du immer einen Adapter benutzen.
Adapter auf Adapter auf Adapter, ja.
... 25-Pin-Serienport.
Das war damals fast normal, dass du für manche Sachen so einen dicken Adapter-an-Adapter-Ding hattest.
Wie haben die das früher ohne RGB gemacht? Ja, das frage ich mich auch.
... Serienport-Design, mit dem 9-Pin,
eröffnet durch das IBM At-Modell,
und bietet eine reduzierte Größe, eine mehr kosteneffiziente Verbindung,
mit einem Subset der vollen Serienkarte.
... Serienport-Standard.
Für die meisten Geräte der Zeit war diese Verbindung mehr als genügend,
obwohl das Design bedeutet, dass sie sich leicht mit einer DB9-Joystick-Verbindung verbinden kann,
wie bei den Atari 2600 oder Sega Mega Drive, zum Beispiel.
Wenn du ein Gerät suchst, wie ein Modem,
dann brauchst du wahrscheinlich den vollen 25-Pin-Port,
mit der Spezifikation für den vollen Serienport.
Viele, und tatsächlich die meisten Geräte,
Guckt euch mal die Werbung an! Guckt euch mal die Werbung an!
... Spezifikation, viele?
Warum liegt die dahinter?
Warum liegt die... Warum liegt die dahinter und guckt so?
Alter, heute werden die Feministen... werden ausrasten bei so einer Werbung!
Vor allem, die liegt voll auf der Kante, du siehst richtig, die ist kurz vor dem runterfallen.
Die meisten Geräte können mit einem Serial-Port verbunden werden.
Aber eines der Hauptprobleme war die Geschwindigkeit.
Ich meine, die Begründung ist im Titel.
Da die Daten in einen einzigen Stream eingeschaltet werden,
anstatt konkurrent mit der maximalen Geschwindigkeit,
meistens mit 115.000 bis 200.000 pro Sekunde.
Kannst du...
Hardware, die generell nicht unterstützt wurde...
Die Chinesen wussten das schon immer.
Es ist It's pro Sekunde.
Und 115k It's pro Sekunde war damals echt viel.
Da hat man sogar noch null Modem-Kabels genommen.
Also quasi zwei PCs per Parallel-Port verbunden mit.
Und hat sich übelst gefeiert.
Da konnte man dann Half-Life 1 übers Netzwerk kopieren.
Innerhalb von zweieinhalb Stunden oder so.
It's pro Sekunde, wohlgemerkt.
Es kann höher werden, abhängig von Hardware,
aber war generell nicht unterstützt
von den meisten Software- und Operationssystemen.
Was ist also mit Parallel-Ports?
Oder z.B. Centronics Parallel-Ports?
Obwohl die originalen Ports nur 150 Kilobit pro Sekunde
beherrschen können,
können die weiterentwickelten Parallel-Ports
bis zu 2,5 Megabyte pro Sekunde beherrschen.
Wie bei den meisten Serial-Port-Applikationen
wird die Daten konkurrently über mehrere von den 25 Pins
ausgeliefert.
Dies macht sie eine ideale Wahl für Printer
und sogar für Geräte, die eine hohe Geschwindigkeit haben,
wie z.B. die Zip-Drive und andere Geräte,
die sich voranbringen.
Ich wollte damals immer einen Zip-Drive haben.
Weil da konntest du 100 MB drauf speichern.
Ich hatte nie einen Zip-Drive.
Aber ich wollte damals immer einen Zip-Drive haben.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wofür ich es hätte verwendet,
wenn ich es hätte.
Aber ich wollte es immer haben, weil 100 MB sauviel waren.
Ich hatte nur die Möglichkeit,
die beiden direktzen Modes auf die späteren Porte zu verändern.
Aber die Parallel-Port-Applikation hat es selbst Probleme.
Der Hauptgrund ist, dass die 8 Daten-Linien
mit einander synchronisiert werden mussten.
Also schieben 8 Bit schneller und schneller
auf die Pins.
Das könnte ein paar Synchronisierungsprobleme verursachen,
die die Anfänge reduzieren.
USB, zum Beispiel, benutzt die Serial-Port-Applikation.
Aber mit Technologie, die einen viel größeren
Freigangsaufbau bietet als unsere vertraute
Also, was ist das für ein Switch?
Äh, Hub USB-Hub.
Hoho!
Wartet mal Leute, was ist das?
Was ist das?
Das ist, das ist eine Soundkarte, eine Soundkarte mit Joystick-Anschluss.
PS2 Serial Parallel?
Modem?
Das ist ein RJ11-Stecker, hä?
Das ist ein Modem?
Ist das ein Modem?
Und, und könnte das hier, könnte das hier eine Grafikkarte sein?
Nee, oder?
Was ist das?
Was ist das hier oben?
Eine uralte TV-Karte?
Nee.
Das könnte echt eine Grafikkarte sein, oder?
Weil ich sehe sonst keinen Grafikausgang hier dran.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein Modem.
Ah, die Werbung damals!
Haha!
Die Werbung damals!
Ach so, ja, Leute, ich habe ganz vergessen.
Ähm, ich muss ein Streamlabs aufmachen, falls irgendjemand heute gesubt, gefollowt
oder sonst was ist, ähm, nicht, dass ich das ganz komplett vergesse.
Na, zum Glück habe ich nichts übersehen.
Danke für die Follows.
Den haben wir hier heute am Start, den Chuck690.
Und ich bin's, ein Fischi.
Sehr schön.
Sechzehn, fünfzehn Volt.
Oh, jetzt hat aber einer gesappt.
Alex, perfekt, 271, Twitch Prime-Sub.
Dazu kann ich bloß sagen.
Nice, danke für den Sub.
Sie haben es damals nicht auch schon wieder verkackt mit Anschlüssen, ne?
Also, obwohl es damals üblich war, separate Plug-In-Karten zu haben, um mit Serial und Parallel-
Wisst ihr was? Damals, damals, ja, haben die Leute schon gedacht, alter, das ist aber eine fette Karte.
Hätten die gewusst, dass Grafikkarten heute drei Slots brauchen und quasi über Gehäusespezifikationen gehen, hätten sie mir das nicht geglaubt.
... Parallel-Port, inklusive einiger obskuren, wie dieser Tandy-All-in-One-Adapter.
Timmy los, danke für den Tandy.
Twitch Prime-Sub, auch hier, nice, ultra-nice.
Drei Slot-Karten, ja, Grafikkarten heute, also überhaupt kein Ding, mit einem fetten Lüfter drauf.
Ich meine, die sagen nicht drei Slot, die sagen zweieinhalb Slot, was aber im Endeffekt, ne, weil einen halben Slot gibt's nicht, also es sind dann einfach mal drei Slots.
Was, ein Riesenanschluss?
Boah, ist das eklig, dreckig.
Aber, das Zeug...
... hat damals echt schnell gegilbt.
Das lag aber auch mit da dran, dass damals noch viel mehr Leute geraucht haben.
Beste.
36K.
336K, oder was war das?
Bei dem hier.
33, 336, ja.
Pock.
Ein Minimalist unverzichtbar.
Und записcht.
Hab ich nur, um gleich ein paar seaweeduge bis dahin, dass man zu denstellbar und
der Withoutandoid ist.
Ich bin zu emissions screwdriver, mit.
Aan die Klinkercards.
Alles wie beim Infinity Hack!
Guuuuh.
Ich mag das so richtig gut.
Also das Virus Of Pock!
Au!
Genau.
Aktuellen Handys nicht mehr.
Oh.
Midi-Adapter.
Damals war alles, wenn du nicht Sound Blaster kompatibel hattest, konntest du vergessen.
Oh ja. Jawoll.
Hat ja bis heute überlebt im Endeffekt, mit SATA.
Bloß, bloß nicht extern.
In der Zeit, in der alle zusammenarbeiten, um ein Problem zu lösen, wurden die Mitglieder jeder Firma von sich aus mit der Ziel, es einfacher zu machen, externen Geräte mit PC zu verbinden, während sie die Bedingungen und die Anwendungsprobleme der heutigen Methoden beantworteten.
Einer der Mitglieder des Teams, der daran gearbeitet hat, war AJ Bat, der bei Intel arbeitete, der die ersten USB-integrierten Zirkel im Jahr 1995 produzierte.
Diese original Spezifikation hat eine Resultatrate von 1,5 Megabit pro Sekunde, bis 12 Megabit pro Sekunde.
Die Werbung damals.
Wahnsinn. USB 1.0.
Ja, Mr. Milchmann hab ich auch.
Für die Apple-Fahrer, ist das ja nicht wirklich der Fall. Es gab FireWire, aber für alle anderen…
Ja, FireWire, stimmt, das gab's ja auch noch.
… stand an der Stelle, in dem wir eine höchste animierte Mode mit 480 Megabit pro Sekunde anbieten.
Uiuiui, USB 2.0.
Genau.
Und auch noch.
Dafür gibt's halt mittlerweile
3 Milliarden verschiedenen USB-Stecker.
Das war ein nices Video.
Das ist echt cool.
Big old Servers.
Oh, das müssen wir jetzt noch gucken.
Ach, so old sind die Dinger hier gar nicht.
Ist das ein Playcenter?
Aber bei Playcenter müssten die Plates eigentlich vorne haben,
aber von der Größe her.
Gucken wir mal.
Figured I'd show you something that I normally don't cover on the channel,
but you might be interested in anyway.
I decommissioned a few servers.
I've got this guy and then a few more over to the other side.
Hallo, Siki.
There's something kind of interesting about this server and the other ones
that you might be interested in.
I don't know.
I'm filming this on my lunch break at work.
This is an IBM X5.
Ich glaube, ich würde ziemlich doof angeguckt werden,
wenn ich bei uns ins RZ gehe, mein Handy raushole
und ein paar Server filme und dann hochlade.
Ja, genau.
Max Reaction.
Team Ilios, danke für den Privance-Hub.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es schon erzählt habe,
aber ich habe es gerade in der Übersicht gesehen.
Falls ich es vergessen habe, dann habe ich es jetzt nachgerollt.
Das ist ein 4HE.
Das ist eine 4HE-Kiste.
Oder sogar noch mehr.
Ich glaube, das ist sogar noch mehr.
Noch mehr als 4.
Na, wobei.
Ah.
Ah, nee.
4.
Ist 4.
Würde ich auch sagen.
IBM hatte auch Kisten, die sich nicht so ganz dran gehalten haben.
Also, die hatten ihre Plate-Senders waren teilweise dann irgendwie auch 16 hoch und sowas.
Oder nicht 16, 8 hoch oder so.
Lass mal den Hood poppen.
Genau.
Ja, oh, die Öffnung kenne ich noch.
Das hatten die ganzen ollen IBM-Dinger.
Und ganz wichtig, Leute.
Wenn ihr jemals, hier oben die Nummer, ne?
Wenn ihr jemals in die Verlegenheit kommt, bei IBM einen Service-Request oder Service-Call aufmachen zu müssen,
ihr braucht die Nummer hier oben.
Das ist die sogenannte FRU-Nummer.
Die FRU-Nummer ist das Einzige, was dem indischen IBM-Support überhaupt sagt, was ihr wollt.
Ihr könnt noch so viele Wörter verwenden.
Das ist egal.
Die FRU-Nummer ist das, was zählt.
Ohne FRU-Nummer, IBM-Support, nix, nix wissen.
Classic IBM.
This system, like I said, from probably 2011, 2012.
It was purchased before I started working here.
But it's also pre-Lenovo-Buyout.
You know, famously, Lenovo ended up buying IBM's hardware, you know, computer hardware business off of them.
And so this is a true IBM system.
Einer der Bots mal, please.
I remember.
I remember having to call in once for support on this years ago.
And I was actually talking to IBM.
Ein Werbungsspam-Typ.
Aber ich hau ihn.
The first thing that makes this box kind of interesting is this setup.
So you unlatch this guy and again trying to do this one-handed.
Ist das doch ein Playcenter?
Sah gar nicht so aus, ne?
Weil die IBM Playcenter haben eigentlich vorne zum rausziehen.
Baut ihr die Kisten eigentlich selbst oder kauft ihr?
Wir kaufen fertige Kisten.
Die meisten Business-Leute, Enterprise-User kaufen fertige Kisten, IBM oder Dell.
Das macht es immer, wenn du entbanntest.
And there we go.
And then you pull this daughter card out.
And you can see there's some RAM on there.
There are 8 RAM-Plots.
DDR3 ECC.
So this is server-grade memory that they are correcting.
Each of these sticks is...
Wir hatten mal, wir hatten auch mal so ein Ding.
Also in Vollaufbau.
Das war, das waren ein paar Testkisten 2000, auch so 2012 oder 2011, also schon eine ganze Weile her.
Und die hatten jetzt ohne Scheiß zu dieser Zeit damals 2 Terabyte RAM.
Das ging natürlich nur, wenn du das mit 64G, mit 64G-Modulen voll bestückt hattest, die kompletten Erweiterungsbänke voll.
Aber ich will nicht wissen, was 2 Terabyte RAM damals gekostet haben.
16 Gigs.
So that's 64 gigs.
64 Giga RAM on this daughter card.
I mean, that's a decent amount for a server, right?
I mean, it's maybe not a spectacular amount, given today's numbers.
But 2011, 2012, 64 Giga RAM was a pretty healthy amount.
Das wird immer noch ordentlich.
So I've got this daughter card with 64 Giga RAM on it.
I never had to try and put this card in one hand.
Das war wirklich ganz cool bei den Dingern damals von IBM.
Du konntest.
Komplett ohne zu schrauben, das meiste.
IBM's merit, das war irgendeine Datenbankgeschichte.
Nee, stimmt nicht.
Stimmt nicht.
Die 2 Terabyte Kiste war nicht für eine Datenbank damals, ich erinnere mich wieder.
Die war für irgendwelche Citrix, Citrix, Citrix Virtualisierungsgeschichten.
Die 2 Terabyte RAM Kiste damals, die wir hatten zum Testen.
Weil wir hatten nicht nur eine Kiste zum Testen, ich glaube wir hatten 10 oder so.
Das war für irgendwelche Citrix Dinger.
Die IBM Dinger sind echt nicht schlecht.
Du kannst das alles ohne Werkzeug austauschen, das meiste.
So, was auch dieses Server etwas besonderes macht, ist, dass es hier unten versteckt ist.
Flipp die Latsche, hol den Kerl hoch und es gibt 4 Heatsinks hier unten.
Was schön ist, ich mag es, wie sie den abwechslungsvollen Handel haben, damit man sie individuell auswählen kann.
Wenn man fragen sollte, wie das mit dem Kühlen überhaupt funktioniert, das ist eigentlich relativ simpel.
Der Luftstrom geht da einfach so durch.
Von vorne nach hinten.
Du hast meistens, vorne saugst du es an und hinten hast du dann deine Klimaanlage, die es absaugt wieder.
Oder warte mal, wo ist überhaupt hinten und wo ist vorne?
Ach, hier ist vorne, sorry, hier ist vorne.
Hier ist vorne, dann zieht es das so rum.
Und die Dinger sind laut.
Also die Dinger sind wirklich laut.
Da ist mal ein Staubsauger-Roboter von gestern nichts dagegen.
Ach stimmt.
Es gibt zwei separate CPUs.
Natürlich sind die meisten Konsumenten-Computern nur ein Staubsauger, aber jeder dieser Staubsauger hat eine separate CPU drin.
Das sind alle Xeon E7 4820 CPUs, glaube ich.
Das ist ein 8-Core 2 GHz Prozessor mit Hyperthreading, also 16 Threads.
Wahnsinn.
Multipliziert das so, dass dieser Server 32 Cores und 64 Threads hat.
Selbst was AMD und Intel tun, ja, du kannst jetzt ein gesundes Niveau Cores aus einer einzigen CPU bekommen.
Aber erinnere dich, 2012, das war ein viel Computer-Kraft in einer einzigen Box.
Also vier CPUs, separate Heatsink für jede.
Jetzt, du kannst dich vielleicht denken, okay, also dieser Server, du weißt, es ist eine ziemlich scharfe Box, viel RAM, viel CPU.
Okay, also was?
Was geht da drüben?
Es gibt so viele Hard-Drives und so, richtig?
Also, wir schauen uns die Vorseite an.
Ein bisschen schwarz, aber du kannst sehen, wir haben diese Drivebays.
Es gibt acht von ihnen.
Sie nehmen 2,5-Inch-SAS-Drives.
Aber wenn wir...
Die Dinger ... du kannst da bestimmt auch ohne Probleme eine Fibre-Channel-Karte und Zeugs einbauen, dass du da mehr Storage ...
Wie schwer ist so eine Kiste?
Ziemlich schwer.
Ehm, wie schwer ist das?
Also die weiß ich jetzt nicht
Aber ich hab mal
Ein IBM Playcenter alleine eingebaut
Als ich noch Azubi war
Das war so ein Ding
Ja genau, so ein Teil
Ähm, das sind 8 HE
Und
Das ist wirklich schwer, das Ding
Ich würd mal sagen, so 50 Kilo oder so
Äh, Max Electronics kann ich machen, ja
Schreib's nochmal, falls ich vergesse
Ich würd mal sagen, so 50 Kilo
Ja, ja, das ist, das ist, das ist
Das ist deres, ja
Und 5 Kilo ist eher
Ein einzelnes Plate, was da drinnen steckt
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob 50 Kilo
Überhaupt reichen
Ja, 85 Kilo, das trifft's, das trifft's
Eher, ich sag euch Leute, das war nicht ohne
Ähm
Und das Einbauen kannst du auch nicht so einfach machen
Also das kannst du nicht machen, wie bei
Weißt du, normale Server kannst du halbwegs
Einfach in den Rack einbauen, wenn du
Machst du Schienen rein
Und, ähm, je nachdem, wie das Ganze gemacht ist
Wie gut die Schienen sind, kannst du es einfach vorne richtig reinmachen
Und gut ist
Oder manche Dinger musst du auch so halb mit nem Arm
Reinhalten und dann festschrauben, ja
Ähm
Aber die, die Plate Center
Die musst du reinheben in die
In die Schienen
Das war nicht so, nicht so easy
Und die IBM Schienen damals hatten auch
Zumindest, vielleicht waren es auch nur unsere
Hatten die Angewohnheit, dass es mal ganz gerne
Verkantet ist und mal ganz, ganz gerne hängen geblieben ist
Da musstest du es dann reinmachen
Und dann musstest du es reinheben
In der Hoffnung, dass du es gleichmäßig reinhebst
Dass es, dass es auf beiden Seiten richtig passt
Sonst musstest du dran ziehen und sowas
Das war schon nicht ohne
Aber ohne Scheiß, Leute
Wenn ich das so sehe, ich muss sagen
Ich mach ja die letzten, ich mach ja schon 10 Jahre
Nichts mehr richtig mit Hardware, ja
Also ein bisschen vermiss ich das schon, ja
Also vor allem, als ich noch Azubi war
Und das ist jetzt, ist ja noch, noch länger her
Ähm
Oder ganz knapp, so lange her
Und dann, ähm, dann hab ich das schon
Da war ich so viel im RZ und hab so viel an Hardware rumgeschraubt
Irgendwie vermiss ich das schon ein bisschen
Einfach so
Da musstest du, da musstest du dir
Um viel weniger
Äh, politische Befindlichkeiten
Irgendwie Gedanken machen, ja
Ähm
Einfach irgendwie, dass einer irgendwas will, der andere will irgendwas nicht
So bei Hardware ist es im Prinzip kein Ding
Du weißt, aha, CPU kaputt, CPU austauschen
Oder Platte kaputt, Platte austauschen
Die Dinge haben auch alle
Ähm, gut, bei dem hier weiß ich nicht
Aber die meisten dieser IBM-Kisten
Haben vorne auch Status-LEDs
Dass du genau siehst, was kaputt ist
Also, in dem Fall muss man sagen
Das ist gar nicht mal komplett überteuerte Server-Hardware
Die waren auch gut, die Dinger
Die waren wirklich nicht übel
Und der ist schon relativ neu, der hat zumindest schon vorne
Einen USB-Anschluss
Ähm
Weil, wie gesagt, die Anschlüsse bei den meisten Sachen
Sind natürlich, sind vorne
Manche Hersteller haben das auch nicht gecheckt
Und haben die Anschlüsse immer noch hinten hingemacht
Aber es ist Absicht, dass die Anschlüsse vorne sind
Manche hatten sogar noch hier unten so ein Mini
So ein Laptop-CD-Laufwerk drin
Ähm, ach nee, da drüben ist schon die HP-Kiste
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein DL3
Nee, ist kein DL380
Ähm, zumindest
Hattest du die Anschlüsse halt vorne
Weil das ist halt das, was du aus dem Rack rausgucken hast
Ja, das ist normal
Naja, entweder hat es
So, how does it boot an operating system?
Well, that's hidden back under this cover
If we flip this up again
And you look really carefully down in there
You'll see a couple of USB-Ports
Okay, die machen das bei USB
That thing looks like a USB-Stick
It pretty much is
In the industry it's called a DOM or disk-on-memory
That particular one I think is 2 GB
And that is the only bit of storage that this server has in it
Um, the idea is, you just boot your operating system
Off of that
Now, Windows obviously isn't gonna fly with that
And most versions of Linux aren't going to fly with that
So
Und was machst du jetzt auf Arbeit, äh, Ben?
Ich mach mal einen Ausrufezeichen Beruf
Da hab ich nochmal versucht zu erklären
What could this server possibly have been used for?
Well, if you work in IT, you've probably guessed it already
But if you don't, it's a VMware box
This thing runs VMware ESXi
Or at least it ran, cause it's decommissioned now
Klingt logisch
Um, so it had a whole ton of virtual machines
Da machst du, da machst du ESX, da machst du ein ESX drauf
Oder eine Virtualisierungsgeschichte
Und, ähm, du verwendest in der Regel die Platten hier vorne gar nicht
Du machst eine Fiber Channel Karte rein hier hinten
Und schließt es halt an dein Storage über Glasfaser an
Lots of RAM and lots of CPU power
But no need for disk
All of the virtual machines, like their storage
Was actually stored on a separate system called a SAN
Or Storage Area Network
It's basically another server
That's got a whole bunch of hard drives
And drives in it are SSDs
And it's sole purpose is to serve up those files
I guess you could say
For things like hypervisors to access their files
Das stimmt ja, das stimmt nicht so ganz, was er erzählt
Aber ich gehe davon aus, er weiß das
Er sagt das bloß, dass das die Leute im Video besser checken
Wenn du dein Storage per Fiber Channel anschließt
Dann ist das unter der Haube
Ähnlich wie wenn du eine Platte reinsteckst, ja
Das ist jetzt nicht auf File-Ebene
Das ist wirklich, ähm, low level
Also da hast du, da gehen keine Infos über Files drüber
Sondern das ist quasi schon Block-Ebene
Also, all of this server and the other ones next to it
They don't have any hard drives in them
because they will just get all of their hard drive storage
Ach, ich würd schon ab und zu mal gern wieder ein bisschen an dem Zeug rumbasteln
So, let's take a look around back
And you can see back here, we've got quite a bit of networking
Mehr Netzwerkarten, please.
Du kannst verschiedene Teile auswählen, wie du sie nutzen möchtest.
Und natürlich hatten wir mehrere Porte für jedes Netzwerk, weil du das natürlich nicht wollen solltest.
Es geht darum, ob ein Netzwerk, eine Karte, ein Kabel oder was auch immer verfehlt wird.
Es gibt also viel Redundanz.
Hier hinten haben wir deine typischen anderen Server-Porte.
Ich glaube, es gibt nicht viele Server, die noch VGA-Porte für Videos haben.
Wo du alles mögliche auf dem Server einstellen kannst.
Und dann hast du halt nochmal hinten...
Das habe ich damals nicht verstanden.
Warum macht man VGA hinten?
Man hätte VGA vorne und VGA hinten machen sollen.
Weil viele sind mit einem Wagen rumgelaufen, haben sich per Monitor und Tastatur angestöpselt.
Und einige hatten auch in ihren Racks so ein KVM-Switch-System.
Das heißt, eigentlich hast du VGA-Ports vorne und hinten gebraucht.
Ich glaube, RSA ist IBM.
Also warum brauchst du wirklich gute Videos?
USB-Porte...
Serial-Porte...
Ein paar Onboard-Ethernet-Porte...
Und dann dieses Management-Port, das Ethernet ist.
Und das bietet eine Webseite, die spezifisch für das Managen der Hardware des Servers bietet.
Das ist das, was sie Light-Out-Management nennen.
Das einzige Problem daran war, dass fast alles Java-basiert war.
Also das ganze Management-Ding.
Ich meine, die Webseite war natürlich eine Webseite.
Aber sobald du ein bisschen mehr machen wolltest, war das alles Java-basiert.
Es gibt verschiedene Namen dafür.
Aber der Punkt ist...
Du kannst es benutzen, um in diese Webseite zu loggen und...
Und ich glaube, das ist auch der Grund, warum mein Hass auf Java herkommt.
Weil diese Remote-Management-Geschichten in Java nie richtig funktioniert haben.
... den Server auf und ab zu poweren und zu sehen, was auf dem Bildschirm ist,
das Keyboard und das Maus-Klick-Anschluss und alles,
nur aus einem Webbrowser.
Das macht Dinge wirklich, wirklich nützlich,
wenn du in einer anderen physischen Location bist als der Server.
Also, wenn das Ding in der Mitte der Nacht nicht funktioniert,
kann ich einfach von zuhause rein,
und sehe, was da los ist,
anstatt in die Arbeit zu fahren oder was auch immer.
Eine sehr nützliche Feature.
Ein weiteres Zeichen, wie biefig dieser Server ist...
Es ist nicht überraschend,
wenn man Servern mit redundanten Power-Supplies sieht.
Es ist ein Standard-Ding.
Die Dinger haben übelst...
Die Dinger haben immer übelst fette Netzteile drin.
Mich würde nicht wundern,
wenn das ein 1200-Watt-Netzteil links und rechts ist oder sowas.
Die haben da immer...
Die offensivsten Netzteile überhaupt drin gehabt.
Die haben da immer... Die offensivsten Netzteile überhaupt drin gehabt.
Auch nur 875, easy!
Ach nee, 2000! 2000!
Ja...
Die haben da immer, die haben da immer so krass fette Netzteile drin in den Dingern.
Wonka Smoke, wenn das anfängt zu fackeln da.
So there are various fans throughout the system, the power supplies themselves have fans built in and then what cools the RAM and the CPUs, since those don't have fans built in, is that around the front here, let's see if I can do this one handed, you can pop these tabs, front panel comes off and then there are fans.
Ach guck mal, hier unten haben sie doch ein CD-Laufwerk noch drin. Das Zeug war wirklich gut. Ihr seht es ja, du kannst das alles ohne Werkzeug tauschen. Also da ist schon ein System dahinter und da hat man sich schon was bei gedacht.
Und die Dinger sind laut.
Ich müsste mal den Felix fragen, ich müsste echt mal den Felix fragen, ob wir sowas bei uns in der Zeit auch aufnehmen können.
Das wäre doch mal was, oder?
Max RZ Tour.
Was kostet so ein Server?
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Ich würde mal sagen so 20k oder so.
Mit ordentlicher Ausstattung.
20.000 oder mehr.
Irgendwie so in dem Dreh ist schwer zu sagen.
20.000.
Die Spezifik ist ein bisschen anders.
Das sind Hewlett Packard HP.
Die DL580 Gen 7s.
Diese Units und die andere, die da unten auf dem Kart sitzen, wurden am gleichen Zeitpunkt gekauft.
Und sie sind die älteren der beiden.
Wir können den Lid auf diesen hier drücken.
Was hat er jetzt, die HP-Dinger, oder?
Und ich zeige euch, was hier ein bisschen anders ist.
Sie haben sehr ähnliche Spezifikausgaben als die IBM.
Habt ihr ein eigenes RZ? Ja, ja, wir haben sogar zwei RZs in Frankfurt.
Jetzt nicht riesengroße.
Aber unser eines RZ besteht aus drei Räumen.
Das eine ist ein, nee, aus vier Räumen.
Das eine ist ein relativ großes Lager.
Das andere ist ein kleines Lager.
Das andere ist der große Raum mit allen Rechnern drin und allen Racks.
Und das andere, der vierte Raum, ist was, wo noch ein bisschen mehr Technik drinsteht.
Ja.
Und das andere RZ ist ähnlich.
Ja, also flächenmäßig sind die RZ schon ziemlich groß, aber man könnte wahrscheinlich noch eine ganze Ecke mehr Hardware einbauen.
Ja, das ist ein RZ, den wir gerade gesehen haben.
Aber das echte Arrangement der Hardware ist eigentlich ein bisschen anders.
Also, ihr könnt hier die Fans sehen.
War das jetzt die HP-Kiste, die ihr aufgemacht habt?
Ja.
Nee, nee, oder? Oder?
Wir sitzen da unten auf der Karte.
Doch, die HP-Kiste hat er aufgemacht.
Wir haben das gleiche hier von vorne gekauft.
Und dann haben wir auch die...
Wie viel Anbindung haben eure RZs so? Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich weiß gar nicht, was wir aktuell haben.
Also, wir hatten jahrelang...
...hatten wir, ähm...
...im...
...quasi für das Gebäude, wo wir...
...wo die meisten Leute drin gesessen haben, waren 2 Gigabit.
Allerdings, ähm...
...mittlerweile dürfte das viel mehr sein.
Also nicht ins RZ, sondern da, wo die Leute drin gesessen haben.
RZ ist mit Sicherheit mehr.
Das ist das, was die built-in Rade-Karte für die SAS-Drives hat.
Hier ist das Backplane für die Power-Supplies.
Ich habe die eingebauten Ratings noch nie verwendet, wenn es nicht anders ging.
Und dann ein paar Auxiliary-Chips für das Handeln von ein paar der built-in-Porten auf der Rückseite.
Genau wie bei der IBM-Unit hier drüben...
...haben diese keine Harddrives in mir.
Sie haben auch 8 2,5-Inch-SAS-Drives.
Aber das sind alles nur Dummies.
Was anders ist, ist, dass anstelle von einem USB-DOM, wie bei der IBM...
...um die VMware-ESXi zu booten...
...hast du eine SD-Karte.
Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Das Gute an der VMware ist, dass sie, wenn sie bootet...
...direkt von RAM läuft.
Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen, eine SD-Karte, die man da reinstecken kann.
Das wäre jetzt neu.
...ungefährlich, wenn man eine Konfigurierung macht, die man sparen will.
In Wahrheit könnte diese SD-Karte...
...wählen, während dieser Server läuft...
...und der Server wäre in Ordnung.
Es würde es nicht interessieren.
Es würde ein bisschen Warnung geben, dass die SD-Karte gefehlt wurde...
...und man es fixieren möchte.
Und wenn man versucht, den ganzen Server zu rebooten...
...wäre es offensichtlich, dass er nicht booten kann.
Aber weil VMware direkt von RAM läuft...
...kommt es gut.
Man sieht, wir haben noch ein paar...
...PCIE-Karten hier drin.
Diese hat zwei Rückseiten.
Was anders ist an dieser Box...
...verglichen mit der IBM...
...ist die Selektion der Netzwerke...
...auf der Rückseite.
Ich habe hier ein paar built-in Gigabit-Porte.
Diese vier Port-Karten sind auch Gigabit.
Aber diese Dual-Port-Karten...
... sind 10 Gigabit.
Genau, das ist...
Das spiegelt die Dinge sehr hoch.
Besonders...
...wenn man den Storage-Ansatz hat...
...um die Daten auf und ab zu bekommen...
...und die VMs aus dem Sand zu fahren.
Wieder einmal...
...multiple Karten...
...für Redundanz...
...und ein Minimum von zwei Linken für alles...
...so dass...
...wenn eine Karte fehlt...
...eine Port fehlt...
...ein Kabel fehlt...
...oder sie entdeckt werden...
...oder was auch immer...
Das sind doch ganz normale R45-Ports...
...aber...
...sieht irgendwie nicht so aus.
Sieht ein bisschen breiter aus.
Übrigens, Leute...
Wir sehen es hier, ne?
VGA und PS2.
4200 Watt Netzteile.
Aber...
...diese Server braucht...
...ein Minimum von zwei Power-Supplies...
...um einfach aufzuwachen.
Das Lights-Out-Management...
...ist effektiv ein Computer im Computer.
Der Server muss nicht...
...aufgewogen werden...
...um das Lights-Out-Management zu funktionieren.
Sobald der Server genügend Kraft erhält...
...beginnt das Lights-Out-Management...
...aufzuwachen.
Also...
...sobald du zwei Power-Karten...
...in der Rückseite hast...
...wird das Lights-Out-Management...
...aufwachen, aufwachen...
...und dann kannst du...
...die Wetter-Interface eigentlich...
...remotely pressen...
...die Power-Button auf der Front.
Aber weil dieser Server...
...mit den CPUs und dem RAM...
...und allem konfiguriert ist...
...mussst du mindestens drei...
...Power-Supplies...
...aufwachen...
...und 24-7...
...für...
...wie auch immer.
Ich habe den Stack...
...einmal durchgemacht...
...und all die Virtual Machines...
...aufgezogen.
Die andere große Unterschiede...
...in diesen Servern...
...verglichen mit den IBM...
...ist, wie die CPU...
...und das RAM...
...verordnet ist.
Es kommt tatsächlich...
...aus dem Inneren...
...haha...
...so es ist quasi...
...das gleiche Arrangement...
...wie bei IBM.
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen...
...so RAM-Einschübe...
...das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Das X5...
...wo du diese...
...separaten...
...Daughter-Karten...
...für den RAM...
...da sind 8 von ihnen...
...in diesem Fall...
...sind alles...
...8 GB RAM-Sticks...
...ähm...
...ein bisschen...
...faster RAM...
...aber...
...ist immer...
...DDR3 ECC...
...dies sind 8 GB...
...aber...
...einer von diesen...
...ist 4 GB...
...aber...
...einer von diesen...
...ist voller Population...
...daher sind 8 Sticks...
...in einer von diesen...
...imstatt von...
...30 Watt...
...TDP-CPUs...
...diesen...
...E7-4820s...
...sind...
...105 Watt...
...TDP...
...wenn...
...Memory...
...sorgt...
...die VMs...
...haben wirklich keine Ahnung...
...welche CPU...
...die sie aufnehmen...
...für jedes...
...RAM-Modul...
...also...
...wenn...
...jemand...
...eine Flasche...
...oder...
...Ein Fehler...
...kann...
...jemand errechnen...
...welcher RAM-Ringel...
...narr sicherlich...
...arts nicht...
...und...
...wenn der RAM-Magnet...
... sincerely...
...herrlich ist...
...wir denken aber...
...einen Informations seres...
... Wrap 허...
...st 2010...
...wenn...
...wir die Schlachtung von...
...Memory...
...und die RAM von...
...mit ihn...
...ist...
...errlich...
...atics...
...wenn...
... Schr שהer...
...n chronisch...
...die neuen...
...An información...
...diper...
...d прыgeln...
kannst, die meisten Server
halb auseinander nehmen kannst, ohne dass du Werkzeug brauchst,
ist schon geil. Auf der anderen Seite
wirkt da vieles Zeugs wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend.
Das ist ganz
merkwürdig. Auf der einen Seite wirkt das richtig cool
und durchdacht und dann guckst du dir die Kisten
an und hast heute VGA-Anschlüsse und
PS2-Anschlüsse
oder Sachen, die nur mit Java
richtig funktionieren. Wie gesagt, die neuen
Dell-Kisten, die haben
jetzt seit einer Weile schon
eine HTML5-Oberfläche
und auch eine Remote-Konsole mit
HTML5, aber ich meine, es ist
2019. Das hätte man
seit 10 Jahren schon machen können, aber
wenn einer, was Technik
angeht, sehr konservativ ist, dann sind das
Serverhersteller. So, jetzt gucken wir
mal als nächstes, was habe ich hier noch drin?
Ist das...
Okay, ich habe
in meiner
später Ansehen-Liste
noch einen Videolink
drin, wo ich keine Ahnung habe, was es ist.
Es könnte jetzt sein, dass es Monkatos ist.
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Gwen131, danke für den Twitch-Prime-Sub.
Battle Bots Basement.
Ach, das ist dies...
Oh Gott, oh nee!
Ich weiß, was das ist. Das ist diese komische
äh, diese komische, ähm, ähm
Fight-Sendung, wo sie so
wo sie so kleine Roboter gegeneinander
gegeneinander, ähm
rennen lassen.
Das ist... Wobei, das ist witzig.
Das ist...
Ja, ja.
Genau, das ist, wo sie diese komischen
Roboter gegeneinander fahren lassen.
Das ist
ehrlich ganz unterhaltsam. Okay, das, die, die
Ansage müssen wir nicht gucken. Wir gucken uns jetzt mal das
das Match an, ja.
Genau.
Der Kram ist... Warum habe ich das
in meiner später Ansehen-Liste drinne?
Und was ist das für...
Was ist das für ein Ding?
Was zum Teufel soll das sein?
Und warum ist das... Warum ist das
Interlaced-Video?
WTF?
Wow! Es brennt!
Es sieht nicht sonderlich elegant aus,
muss man sagen, ne?
Woran erkennst du, dass es Interlaced ist?
Wenn es Streifen hat bei schneller Bewegung.
Was ein Kram!
WTF, ey?
Okay, Moment.
Moment. Musik. Musik.
Wartet mal.
Das... Das... Das...
Das...
Mehr...
Genericste...
Ähm... Metal-Ding zum
unterlegen von sowas, ey.
Das sieht so...
So behäbig aus, irgendwie.
Vor allem, wie das Ding
versucht, immer wieder aufzustehen.
Sieht wirklich aus
wie ein Mülleimer. Das Ding sieht echt aus wie Mülleimer.
Oh, jetzt wird da abgefackelt.
Haben die sich
irgendwie gerade ein bisschen verhakt?
Der Toaster
kämpft gegen Frosch. Sieht echt
so aus.
Oh, jetzt.
Grip.
Kaputt. Kommt das nochmal
hoch, das Ding?
Warum genau gucke ich mir das jetzt an?
Die...
Die Konstruktion von dem Teil wirkt
noch nicht so ganz ausgereift.
Das Grill hat gewonnen.
Oh, Mann.
Was es für ein Kram
gibt, ey.
Was es für ein Kram gibt.
Jetzt wird erstmal in die Luft Flammen
werfert.
Wird in die Luft gehackt.
Macht das Ding hier auch irgendwas?
Außer, dass es
abgefackelt... Oh.
Es sieht schon irgendwie ein bisschen behäbig
aus, oder?
Oh. Oh, er hat sich selbst
kaputt gemacht.
Es hat sich selbst zerstört.
Der andere hat überhaupt nichts gemacht.
Der andere hat einfach nur da gestanden.
Es hat sich selbst zerstört.
Vorbei.
Kennst du AVE? Ne, sagt mir nichts.
Was ist AVE?
Alien vs. Alien?
Tja, es hat sich
ausgejommt, würde ich sagen.
Der musste nicht wirklich
was machen. Der musste einfach nur da stehen, während
sich der andere selbst zerstört.
Ufo versus, ähm, mir fällt nichts ein, was das andere sein könnte.
Warum, warum existiert sowas überhaupt?
Ich mein, irgendwo ist es ganz unterhaltsam, ja?
Aber, warum gibt's sowas?
Pizzakarton, ja.
Pizzakarton, nee, das ist nicht mal Ufo, das ist so ein Kreisel, wie es früher für die Kinder gab, so zum Aufpumpen und dann zzzzt.
Warum, warum, warum existiert so ein, eine Fernsehsendung, warum gibt's die?
Wer kommt auf die Idee vor allem, sowas zu machen?
Ich mein, unterhaltsam ist es irgendwo, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich mir das zwei Stunden am Stück angucke.
Oh, jetzt ist es vorbei.
Nee, oh, es lebt noch.
Das Ufo ist richtig OP, ja.
Oh, es ist, ich glaub, ich glaub die Räder beim Ufo sind kaputt.
Ich glaub die Räder vom Ufo sind kaputt.
Es bewegt sich nicht mehr.
Das Ufo hat sich ausgeUFOt, es dreht sich noch, aber es fährt nicht mehr.
Aber drehen tut sich noch.
Der Counter-Typ, ja.
Was es nicht alles gibt.
Ach ja, oh man.
Warum, warum, ich mein, warum nicht, ja?
Aber schon, was es nicht alles gibt.
That's a knockout, ja.
Ich mein, es dreht sich zwar auf der Stelle noch.
Gucken wir mal, ob hier mein...
NetElectric...
...Electro...
...Electro-Boom.
Ob er neue Videos hat.
Nee, hat er nicht.
Kenne ich alle schon.
Wie gesagt, den Channel kann man echt empfehlen.
Wer sich für ein bisschen Elektronik-Krams äh, interessiert, Videos, die unerhaltsam sind.
Wollen wir mal eins gucken.
Das mit der Dusche war auch nice.
USB-Killer.
Make...
Oh Gott.
Der Heat & Seat ist nice.
Okay, komm, wir nehmen den Heat & Seat.
Hi.
Ups.
...great and unique idea, which is turning your wooden or plastic seat into a heated seat so your fragile buttocks can rest in peace.
All we need is a heating element, which I'll extract from this broken hairdryer as these wires.
So here we are.
I hot glued these wires to my seat with their end connected to a cable...
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass er sich mindestens 20 mal selber schockt in dem Video.
...and just plug into the wall.
Okay, there we are.
...and there we are.
Oh Mann.
Die Hose brennt, Alter.
In hindsight, mounting a heating element with hot glue is a pretty dumb idea because the glue can melt and stick somewhere else...
...and also evidently sitting on super hot live water...
Hmm, Mann.
Super hot live wires is a terrible, terrible idea, as my bot can confirm.
Hä, das ist doch gestellt.
Nee, das ist bei dem in jedem Video so.
Der ist hart im Nehmen.
Natürlich ist es, naja, was heißt gestellt?
Ihm wird schon klar sein, dass es keine, dass es keine, keine gute Idee ist.
Aber da macht er es wirklich.
But we shall not be discouraged.
There are other heating elements we could use.
Wonka Smoke ist bei dem angesagt.
...heating elements that we can unplug easily.
The good thing about this is that the live wires are hidden inside the elements.
So you won't get shocked if you touch them.
Seinen Herd nimmt er auch gern auseinander.
Das hat er in ganz, in ganz vielen Videos nimmt er seinen Herd immer auseinander.
Also in North America they run on over 200 Volt AC.
So if I run in 120 Volt, I should avoid superheating it.
Das ist Absicht, das ist aber nicht gestellt, in dem Sinn, dass es fake wäre.
So connecting it to power, you won't get a shock, although it's drawing around 6 Amps.
Now I don't know what metal it's made of.
I'm guessing iron, but it's hardly conductive, so it's safe to touch.
Of course, getting shocked is not the only concern.
Obviously, this thing is a heating element and can get very hot, even if I run it on 120 Volt AC.
And it's pretty uncomfortable to sit on anyway.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
So I went and bought some other heating elements.
This one is pretty small.
Wie ist der Typ noch am Leben?
Ganz einfach, der weiß, was er macht.
Der weiß, was er macht.
Wie gesagt.
Die Videos sind echt unterhaltsam, aber man lernt auch viel.
Maybe you can use it to heat a baby or, as intended, electric charcoal starter.
Don't use it on babies, you idiots.
But this one is pretty nice and fits my seat well and is made for 240 Volt, 3000 Watts,
which is very similar to my oven element.
I will be running it on 120 Volt AC, which means four times less power or 750 Watts.
So I'm going to run it on 120 Volt AC, which means four times less power or 750 Watts.
It can still burn, so I'm planning to reduce the power to it using a light dimmer.
It says this dimmer is compatible with incandescent lights as well as new dimmable lights,
Das kommt passiert laufend in seinen Videos.
Genau, Oszilloskop Sellout kommt auch immer.
Und so, wenn ich diese beiden Kontakte abschalte, öffnet sich das Licht.
Und wenn ich versuche, dies zu probieren...
Ich versuche, das Programm zu verbinden, ohne mich zu erschöpfen.
Oh, tatsächlich, sie teilen den gleichen Boden.
Ich brauche nicht den Boden zu verbinden.
Okay, jetzt ist die gelbe Linie die Input-Voltage und die rote ist der Ausdruck.
Und wenn ich es öffne,
siehst du, dass ich, wenn ich das hier schließe,
eine Teil des Ausdrucks entfernt wird.
Es ist hier im Minimum und hier im Maximum.
Und so reduziert dies den effektiven AC-Voltage-Ausdruck
über einen resistiven Druck.
Aber Dinge wie LED-Lampen sind nicht unbedingt wie ein resistiver Druck.
Obwohl meine LED-Lampe aussehbar ist und funktioniert gut mit diesem Dimmer.
Flickert ein wenig bei niedriger Voltage.
Der alte Dimmer, den ich getestet habe,
ist aus einem Solid-Stand- oder Silikon-Schalter gemacht,
wie ein Transistor,
der auch die Sachen zwischendrin immer richtig gut erklärt.
Und in diesem Fall ist es ein Triac,
welches ein zweidirektierter Schalter ist.
Äh, zu viele Worte.
Im Grunde ist es ein offenes Zirkus zwischen den beiden Haupt-Terminals,
bis du den Strom in den Gate-Terminal sendest.
Und dann schaltet es sich auf und bleibt auf,
solange du den Strom durchfährst.
Selbst nachdem du das Gate-Signal entfernt hast.
Und dann schaltet es sich nur weiter auf.
Und dann schaltet es sich auf und bleibt auf,
solange du den Strom durchfährst.
Es ist zweidirektierter,
das bedeutet, dass der Strom durch es beide Wege fliegt
und entsprechend getriggert werden muss.
So, das ist der AC-Input
und wir haben einen resistiven Lauf,
wie ein In-
Was hast du schon?
Alan Musks Neuralink gesehen.
Ne.
Neuralink klingt hier.
Big Brain.
Und sagen wir, dass das die Trigger-Pulse
zum Input des Triacs sind.
Die Ausdruck-Voltage ist 0 bis zum Ende des Triggers
und dann schaltet sich der Schalter auf
und der Ausdruck folgt dem Input.
Bis die Voltage 0 erreicht,
was bedeutet, dass der Strom durch den Resistor 0 ist.
Und es schaltet sich auf und wieder auf
durch den nächsten Teil des Triggers
und folgt dem Input wieder und...
So, ich hoffe, ihr habt aufgepasst.
Nächsten Stream wird das Ganze abgefragt.
... wie wir es im Skop gesehen haben.
Nun, indem wir den Dimmer-Knopf bewegen,
bewegen wir die Location dieser Trigger-Pulse,
die den Zeitraum des Triacs verändert
und die Ausdruck-Fähigkeit kontrolliert.
Also zum Beispiel,
wenn dieser Puls früher passiert,
mehr der Voltage,
also der Zeitraum des Triacs,
geht raus.
Das Fahrzeug mit den Induktiv- und Kapazitäts-Lösen
ist ein ganz anderer Mist,
weil der Strom 90 Grad phase-geschaltet ist
und 0 wird, wenn die Voltage auf dem Peak ist.
Okay, schauen wir mal,
was der neue Dimmer anders macht.
Er macht das gleiche Scheiß.
Also was?
Er ist mit LED-Lampen kompatibel,
weil die neuen LED-Lampen
designt sind, dass sie dimmen können.
Und das nimmt den Kredit.
Was zur Hölle?
Fuck!
Schießt nicht Live-Zirkel,
weil sie sich zurückwerfen können.
Ansonsten schauen wir mal,
welche LED-Lampen dimmbar und nicht dimmbar sind.
Ich werde verschiedene Lampen filmen,
mit meiner Kamera in Slow-Motion,
um zu sehen, welche Unterschiede wir sehen.
Hier ist der Inkandensator.
Wie erwartet,
verändert sich die Helligkeit durch den AC-Zyklus.
Hier ist der dimmbare LED.
Er funktioniert wie der Inkandensator.
Und hier ist das unzimmige Licht
und sein Ausgangslicht ist konstant.
Also ist das dimmbare LED-Licht
designt,
abhängig von der Amplität des AC-Voltages.
Deswegen können wir es dimmen,
mit der Veränderung des AC-Voltages.
Aber das unzimmige Licht,
das unzimmige LED,
wird an einem dimmer gehalten.
Denn es ist designt,
um einen konstanten Ausgangslicht
abhängig von der AC-Voltage zu haben.
Also,
für die größte Teilnahme
sieht man,
dass es einen konstanten Ausgangslicht hat.
Aber bei sehr niedrigen AC-Voltagen
kratzt es sich aus.
Beide haben ihre eigenen Vorteile.
Einer bietet Dimmabilität,
während der andere
einen festen Ausgangslicht bietet,
abhängig von den Input-Fluktuationen.
Wir werden gestreckt,
wenn du den dimmer auf deinem Keter schaust.
Wir messen die Voltage
und die Temperatur des Heaters.
Hier haben wir Voltage und Temperatur.
Und wenn wir es auf Minimal schalten,
ist es nur um 4V.
Und es heizt sehr langsam auf.
Aber wir können es aufräumen.
Ich glaube, die Frage,
die man sich nicht stellen darf,
ist, warum man so etwas machen sollte,
sondern eigentlich, weil es geht.
Es heizt schneller.
Und dann wieder aufräumen.
Da ist es.
Sehr schön.
Jetzt haben wir einen industriellen Seatschleifer
für deine dicken Bohnen.
Oh, die Dimmer-Box sagt,
dass sie mehr als 600 Watt handeln kann.
Aber wir könnten max. 750 Watt fahren.
Oh, na gut, ich habe eine Lösung dafür.
Da, ich habe zwei Teile des Sticks verkleidet,
um zu limitieren, wie weit du den Knopf schalten kannst.
Wir brauchen nicht mehr als eine Halte.
Da, jetzt ist alles, was du brauchst,
ist, diese Sache in einer Kuschel zu kaufen
für die Sicherheit und sich darauf zu sitzen.
Auf der anderen Seite,
wenn jemand diese Stücke ungeheuer bräuchte
und sie zu Maximum setzte,
könnte es den Heater oder den Dimmer überheizen,
um das Haus auf Feuer zu setzen.
Wir könnten ein sehr gutes System designen,
in dem ein Mikro-Kontroller
die Temperatur des Heater-Elementes monitoriert
und PWMs den Ausgangspotenzial
um die Temperatur genau darauf zu kontrollieren,
was du verwendest,
mit einem sophisticateden
und fahrsicheren Kontroll-Algorithmus.
Wer denkst du, dass ich bin?
Destin an smarter every day?
All I need is one of these food temperature sensors
and tie it to my heating element.
See, what I've done is that
I cut the housing and remove the glass
and I also glue the piece of wire here to the housing,
that can move now.
And normally this needle could move freely
when the temperature rises.
But now, as the temperature rises,
the needle gets stuck to this piece of wire.
So the temperature can't rise anymore
because the needle is stuck.
Is that how it works?
Because the needle is stuck
or the temperature could be rising.
It's just not showing it.
I think we need to do better.
Here I did one more thing.
I added a piece of wire here
connected to the shaft of this thing,
that's also shorted to the housing.
So now when the temperature rises,
the gauge shorts the housing
to this piece of wire here
and acts like a thermal switch.
Here's the plan.
I have a normally closed relay
that drives the heater element
and its coil is driven by my thermal switch
and is supplied through a diode resistor and capacitor.
I also keep the dimmer
so I can adjust the rate of temperature rise.
Now what happens is that
when I plug in the AC,
the relay switches on and heats up
as well as my thermal switch
that's connected to it.
When the temperature reaches the threshold
that I set with my thermal switch,
the switch closes and energizes
the coil of the relay
and the relay switches over
and turns off the heater element.
Now the heater cools down
and when it cools down below the threshold,
the switch opens and de-energizes the coil
and the relay switches back over
and the heater turns on,
heating back up again.
The switch is now controlled
around my set temperature.
So you could almost say
Easy as fuck!
I'm gonna use a 12V wall adapter
to drive my coil
because with the relay I have
that resistor would turn into a light bulb
and we plug it in.
There we go.
Now the heater is on
and you'll see that the gauge will start rising.
It works!
Not bad!
Of course there is a delay
to get through to the thermometer
and so the temperature
overshoots a bit and drops down afterwards.
At which point the thermometer switch
should open again.
There, the heater is back on
and the needle moves back up again.
Great, now I can shove
all these into a cushion.
There,
now we just plug it in.
Oh, they sell seat warmers for cheap.
Wasn't this a good video?
Did you learn something?
Then subscribe for God's sake!
I'm trying to beat this guy Bobby Duke in sub-
Könnt ihr echt machen, also das ist wirklich ein guter Channel.
Wenn er nicht gesubbt ist,
kann ich ihn subben, das ist echt nice.
So, was hat er denn gefangen?
Was, Alan Musk
Neuralink hab ich schon.
Was soll das sein?
Alan Musk will uns ans Gehirn.
Versuch ein Mensch bereits nächstes Jahr
Was?
Was hat er vor?
Das wäre ja schon mal cool, wenn
er die anderen Sachen mal irgendwie soweit
fertig macht, aber egal, du musst
neues Zeug immer basteln.
Ein Brain-to-Computer-Interface
Gib dir die Präsentation
Äh
Okay
Wie ist das Ding?
Ach, nicht Neuralink
Okay
Moment
Hat der Typ den Fernseher gefilmt?
Kann das sein?
Also das wäre jetzt auch das Letzte, was ich machen würde.
Ich würde garantiert Alan Musk nicht an mein Hirn lassen.
Moment, das gehörte schon dazu.
Öh
Setzen die da gerade irgendwie einem was ein
in den Kopf oder was ist das?
Öh
Glückwunsch zur Partnerschaft, dankeschön.
Habe ich euch übrigens schon erzählt,
dass wenn ihr einen Twitch, ähm
wenn ihr einen Amazon Prime Account habt,
dass ihr den umsonst mit Twitch verbinden könnt
und dann kriegt ihr Twitch Prime Loot
kostenlos und ihr könnt einmal im Monat
einen Streamer eurer Wahl mit einem
Twitch Prime Sub unterstützen.
Was ist das für eine Auflösung?
Schaffen die es nicht, ihre super High-Tech
Präsentation mit einer Kamera aufzunehmen,
die auch ordentliche, ordentliche
äh, oh
Ich hab meinen Sub gesubbt.
Sync
XP, Twitch Prime, dankeschön.
Hi Sue
Hohoho
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe ja schon ein paar Präsentationen geguckt,
ne, ich habe das Gefühl,
die Präsentation, woran er da steht,
die bestehen in der Regel im Publikum
immer nur als, nur so als,
zum größten als aus irgendwelchen Einschleim-Leute,
ja, weil du hast immer Leute im Publikum sitzen,
wenn er irgendwie so einen billigen Joke macht,
siehst du, hörst du immer Leute im Publikum
hohoho
und sowas.
...
äh
um ...
um zu Blessed
a
Ja gut, das lernt man sogar in der Schule schon.
Also, zumindest wenn man aufgepasst hat.
Oh, POC, ein echtes neuronales Netz.
Krasser Scherz.
Easy.
Ja, natürlich hast du auch blaue Lichter im Kopf.
Du hast da noch nicht reingeguckt.
Du weißt gar nicht, ob das so ist.
Allowing recording of the information represented by a neuron.
Our goal is to record from and stimulate spikes in neurons.
Und die Pressekonferenzen von dem, oder die Präsentationen von dem sind immer so übelst langweilig.
Ich fand auch diese Wir-Fliegen-zur-Mars-Präsentation übelst langweilig.
Wisst ihr was, Leute? Wir lesen uns jetzt mal durch, um was es bei der Sache überhaupt geht.
Ich habe keinen Bock, die Präsentation.
Ich habe keinen Bock, die Präsentation mehr anzugucken.
Also, was will er machen?
Die von 2016 gegründete will ein direktes Interface zwischen dem menschlichen Gehirn und Computer herstellen.
Ein Brain-to-Computer-Interface.
Okay, bla bla bla.
100 Millionen, das ist aber ganz schön wenig, oder?
Für so eine bahnbrechende neue Technik.
Der Roboter zum Implantieren der ultradünnen Fäden, welche den Signalaustausch ermöglichen, soll tief ins Gehirn bereits...
Ey, der Satz ist komisch, oder?
Ja, der Roboter zum Implantieren der...
Ultradünnen Fäden, welche den Signalaustausch ermöglichen sollen, tief ins Gehirn, ist bereits funktionsfähig und wurde von Laboraten...
Der Satz ist irgendwie komisch.
Zumindest will er irgendwelche Fäden ins Gehirn anbauen.
Aktuell ist es zum Implantieren der Fäden noch nötig, Löcher in den Schäden...
Also, wenn ich irgendwie einen nicht an meinen Kopf lassen würde, dann garantiert ihn.
Die Forscher hoffen aber dazu, bald Laser nutzen zu können.
Fuck.
Und wozu?
2020 versuchen am Menschen...
Tja, da...
Na gut, es finden sich genug Leute, die da freiwillig mitmachen.
Aus mehreren im Schädel implantierten Chips an den Fäden hängen, die in etwa der Größe einer Nervenzelle entsprechen.
An den Fäden sind Elektronen ange...
Äh, Elektroden angebracht, die den Signalaustausch zwischen Neuralink und den Nervenzellen ermöglichen.
Ja, aber warum?
Also, was hat man denn davon jetzt?
So soll es möglich sein, etwa 40 Wörter pro Minute zu denken.
Also, die neuesten, die, die, die, quasi, die, das ist dann nicht Text-to-Speech, das ist dann Brain, nee, nee, nee, nicht, ähm, nicht Speech-to-Text, das ist dann Brain-to-Text.
Also, also, wenn das, wenn das Beste ist, was wir damit machen können, wenn Computer Wörter aufschreiben lassen können, dann ist, äh, naja.
Außerdem, wie schnell ist jemand, der gut tippen kann, 40 Wörter pro Minute, die Datenübertragung, Bluetooth.
Das heißt, die Chips in meinem Hirn kommunizieren...
...mit Bluetooth mit meinem Smartphone.
Yeah.
Das stimmt, das, das klingt tatsächlich sinnvoll.
Amputierten, blinden Tauben und stummen Menschen helfen später.
Ähm, ja, wobei ich irgendwie so meine Bedenken hab, dass das tatsächlich das Ziel der ganzen Sache ist.
Daten ins Gehirn einfügen.
Bewegung aus dem Kampfsport, ist das dann wie in Matrix?
Ich kann Kung-Fu.
Das wirkt für mich alles ziemlich vage, was das Ganze machen soll.
Das wirkt noch ziemlich...
Das wirkt noch ziemlich vage.
An sich finde ich...
...nicht schlecht, in dieser Richtung natürlich, das, das weiter zu forschen und zu gucken, was, was, ähm, was man machen kann.
Aber ich würde mich ehrlich gesagt nicht freiwillig melden.
Ich hoffe, das läuft nicht auf Windows, äh.
Vielleicht kann man so in 100 Jahren Alzheimer heilen.
Ja, es gibt, äh, stimmt, viele Möglichkeiten damit, was man da machen kann.
Wann denkst du, du bekommst Sub-Emotes?
Ähm...
Ich muss jetzt erstmal meinen...
...Emote-Prefix approven lassen.
Und dann kann ich Sub-Emotes machen.
Und dann brauche ich noch...
...einen Designer, der gute Emotes machen kann.
Bildschirm!
Arbeiter!
Twitch Prime!
Was ist dein Prefix?
Ich weiß noch nicht, was ich nehme.
Ich würde ja am liebsten Max nehmen.
Also mit 4, so wie auf YouTube.
Weil man das schön einprägsam und, und man sich das gut merken kann.
Ähm, aber ich glaube, der ist bestimmt schon belegt.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass der schon belegt ist.
Ich kann das gerade mal ausprobieren.
Partner.
Emotes.
Eindeutiges Prefix.
Max.
Probieren wir mal aus, ob das funktioniert.
Stells.
Wupp.
Was ist besser, Wupp oder Max?
Max ist schon, schon einprägsamer, oder?
Also ich würde sagen, wir machen Max.
Und wenn Max nicht geht, machen wir Wupp oder sowas.
Das Emote-Prefix ist bereits verwendet.
Bitte wähle ein anderes.
Geht schon mal nicht.
Da müssen wir mal im nächsten Stream, ähm, uns Gedanken machen, was wir da nehmen.
Wupp.
Wupp ist irgendwie, hm.
Aber Wupp in Kombination kann man irgendwie wenig machen, oder?
Ne, das ist zu lang.
Es müssen drei Buchstaben sein.
Ich probiere mal Wupp.
Okay, Wupp wird funktionieren.
Wupp.
Dein Prefix wurde zur Genehmigung eingereicht.
Vielen Dank für deine Geduld.
Dann warten wir es mal ab.
Was?
Wir wollen aber 187 als Prefix.
Warum denn 187?
Was ist denn 187?
Ich habe nur gerade was gelesen.
Max hat Brain Lag.
Hardcore Brain Lag.
Euronics.eu.
Twitch Primes Up.
Dankeschön.
Nice.
Was passiert eigentlich, wenn man das Emote nimmt?
Und...
Ah.
Ach, ich war auch noch so schlau und habe das eingestellt, dass das Seitenverhältnis erhalten bleibt.
Ich kann den jetzt gar nicht irgendwie umformen oder so.
Ja Leute, ich würde sagen, wir sind wach, oder?
Sind wir wach?
Ich würde sagen, wir sind wach.
Zwei Stunden.
Max, ich habe mal eine ganz andere Frage.
Warum sind es bei 144 Herzmonitoren eigentlich genau 144?
Wieso genau diese Zahl?
Hm.
Ich würde sagen, das ist irgendeine Bandbreitengeschichte aus dem Bauch raus.
Aber so wirklich sicher bin ich mir da nicht.
Also, ich rate jetzt mal und dann gucken wir nach.
Ich rate jetzt mal und dann gucken wir nach.
Ich denke mal, das liegt daran, dass sie sich überlegt haben,
was kriegen wir maximal durch eine DVI bzw. HDMI, was auch immer damals aktuell gewesen ist,
wie kriegen wir da maximal durch?
Bei 1080p, 32-bit Farbtiefe und wie viel, wie viel, wie viel mal pro Sekunde kriegen wir das da maximal durch?
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie dann bei 144 gelandet sind.
Ich habe aber ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung.
Der Knäherbär sagt 12, 24, 30, 60, 120, 144.
Ja, die Frage ist aber, warum?
Patrick sagt auch, hat was mit Bandbreite zu tun.
Ja, das gehe ich auch von aus.
Willst du den Clip mal anschauen?
Was denn für ein Clip?
Weil es ein Vielfaches von 24 ist.
Aha.
Okay, das könnte sein.
Aber warum muss es ein Vielfaches von 24 sein?
Ich meine, 60 ist auch kein Vielfaches von 24.
Weil, wir fragen einfach mal Google, warum 144?
Wie kommt man auf den Wert 144 beim Monitor?
Dann lass uns das doch mal...
Was ist das für eine Seite?
Ah, weil es ein Vielfaches von 24 ist, 24 der Standard für Filme.
Äh.
Okay, es ist tatsächlich, wohl liegt es daran, dass es ein Vielfaches von 24 ist.
Ja, und, und, und, es hat was, dann passt das.
Man, man will ein Vielfaches von 24 haben und man hat das höchste Vielfaches von 24 gesucht,
was über Duolink DVI drüber geht.
Das ergibt Sinn.
Hey, 2003 ist, also generell ist das gut, wenn es ein bisschen älter ist,
weil die Frage ist ja auch schon ein bisschen älter.
Das klingt sinnvoll.
Man hat ein Vielfaches von 24 gesucht.
Man hat das höchste Vielfaches von 24 gesucht, was bei Full HD über ein Duolink DVI passt.
Das ergibt, eigentlich, eigentlich ergibt das Sinn.
Evoli, was, was soll ich mir denn anschauen für einen Link?
Der Typ unten im Samt, äh.
Der sieht ein bisschen, äh, schockiert aus, dass, äh, er in einem Video gelandet ist, irgendwie.
Was ist das?
Okay.
Evoli, was, was ist das?
Okay, here we go.
Fuck.
Moment.
Was soll das sein?
Fuck.
Was, was gucke ich da?
Evoli, was hast du mir da geschickt?
Was ist das denn?
Das funktioniert nicht so ganz, oder?
Let's continue.
I'm sorry folks, but we're gonna have to watch it like this.
If you have a problem, get the fuck out of my stream.
Let's continue.
Scheint nicht so ganz zu funktionieren, oder?
Okay, was auch immer.
Keine Ahnung.
Kannst du noch die Fragen aus dem PPGaBoard beantworten?
Ja, kann ich.
Kann ich.
Monitor-Geschichten hatten wir, Monitor hatten wir, Clip hatten wir, 144 Shards hatten wir.
Haben wir da überhaupt noch Fragen drin?
Ist die Samsung S360 Evo für 100 Euro ein guter Deal?
Ich habe mir doch auch eine gekauft.
Ich habe mir doch auch jetzt letztens...
Ich habe mir eine 970 Evo gekauft.
Wir kriegen das eigentlich relativ.
960 Evo, was ist eine NVMe oder eine SSD?
Eine 860 Evo für 100 Euro, naja.
Achso, keine Ahnung, ob das ein guter Deal ist.
Kriegen wir raus, was die anderen dafür haben wollen.
Ja, 100 Euro klingt ganz okay.
100 Euro klingt doch ganz okay.
Mittlerweile sind die Dinger echt billig geworden.
Beim Prime, ja, ich habe auch die 970.
Ich habe übrigens noch hier jetzt liegen,
eine 2TB.
1TB SSD und eine 1TB SSD zum...
Das müssen wir auch mal machen demnächst, weil...
Ich habe ja gesagt, ich will...
Ich brauche ein bisschen mehr Speicher.
Okay, ja.
Also ich wollte eigentlich mal meinen Gaming-Rechner hier neu installieren,
auf der 1TB NVMe SSD und dann noch die 2TB SATA SSD dran machen.
Ich habe hier noch...
Ich habe ja eigentlich noch eine 6TB Magnetplatte dran.
Die reicht mir eigentlich auch.
Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, ich mache das ganz anders.
Ich mache die 1TB NVMe SSD rein hier im Desktop,
lasse die 6TB Platte dran für Speicher
und mache die 2TB SSD in mein NAS rein.
Weil, dann geht es dann flutschend, das wenigstens ordentlich.
Dann lohnt es sich wenigstens mal, dass ich eine 10G in der Zweckkarte drin habe.
Okay, was gab es sonst noch für Fragen?
Das habe ich schon beantwortet.
Ich habe ganz viele Kisten mit alten Kabeln.
Die müsste ich echt mal wegschmeißen,
weil kein Mensch braucht so viele Verlängerungskabel
oder irgendwelche Klinkenkabel oder Olle für die...
Ich habe noch Kabel für die Wii und sowas.
Ich habe noch nicht mal eine Wii, die ich auch damit anschließen könnte.
IDE-Kabel, ja.
Ne, kenne ich nicht.
Ist der Zix eigentlich nur ein großer Switch oder macht er noch mehr?
Ach, du meinst den D6.
Das ist im Prinzip ein ganz viel großer Switch, ja.
Kennst du den Dolphin-Emo?
Ja.
Habe ich aber schon lange nicht mal ausprobiert, wie gut das mittlerweile funktioniert.
Es soll ja mittlerweile ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich gut sein.
Du kannst ja auch mit...
Du kannst ja mittlerweile sogar Breath of the Wild ganz gut emulieren auf dem PC.
Ja, genau.
Ich könnte mir auch so einen Stuhl, so eine Heizung für den Stuhl bauen.
Homepage von Stack Overflow hatten wir im Morgen, habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Was nutzt du eigentlich an Router?
Muss man meine Unity-Media-Shitbox tauschen?
Naja, das Problem ist, also das Ding, was ich an Router verwende, ist halt hinter der Unity-Media-Shitbox,
weil mein Router ist halt ein Router und kein Kabelmodem.
Das heißt, man braucht die Unity-Media-Shitbox auf jeden Fall.
Mikrotik-Sellout.
Na, als Ersatz für eine Unity-Media-Box lohnt sich halt die Mikrotik-Geschichte nicht.
Ich habe halt die Unity-Media-Box und Mikrotik dahinter.
Übrigens, Leute, morgen ist es soweit.
Morgen wird die Telekom abgeschaltet bei mir.
Und dann ein paar Tage später gibt es Upgrade, Unity-Media, 40 Mbit ab, 400 down.
Und das ist aber schon von gestern die Frage.
Habe ich irgendwelche Fragen übersehen?
Hast du immer noch Dual-Stack-Line?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe Unity-Media lang genug genervt,
lang genug genervt, dass mich dann irgendwann samstags mal ein Techniker von Unity-Media angerufen hat
und gesagt hat, ich soll es mal ausprobieren, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Und sieh da, es hat funktioniert, es ist wieder IPv4.
Und der Support auf Twitter hat mir auch versichert,
dass ich durch das Upgrade weiterhin IPv4 behalte,
beziehungsweise sie das sofort wieder umschalten sollte es nicht passieren.
Können wir mal gucken, wie sehr das funktioniert, was Unity-Media da so schreibt.
Kannst du nicht einfach ein Kabelmodem holen?
Doch, doch, klar.
Aber ich finde ein bisschen unsinnig, weil man hat ja von Unity-Media schon eins.
Warum sollte ich mir noch eins holen?
Der einzige Unterschied ist halt, dass ich dann nur...
einen Modem habe und nicht noch quasi dieses, dieses, dieses, diesen verkappten Unity-Media-Router dazwischen.
Wollt ihr mir für Backups eine USB3-Dockingstation für SATA-Festplatten kaufen, schreibt der omgitsmo.
Ähm, gibt aber...
Vielleicht soll ich mal das E-Mode wegmachen.
Ach.
Wollt ihr mir eine für SATA-Festplatten...
Gibt aber nur welche von Billigfirmen mit relativ viel eine-Sterne-Reviews.
Ähm...
Kennst du da eine gute Alternative zur Docking-Station?
Da gibt's doch...
Also ich hab von Sharkoon mal so ein Ding gekauft und das funktioniert seit Jahren schon ganz gut.
Ich hab so ein Ding von...
Das Ding hab ich mal gekauft vor...
vor...
Ewigkeiten.
Und das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut.
Aber es ist halt nur USB3.
Das ist Billig-China-Ding?
Hehe.
Moonbeard-Desmond.
Ja.
Ähm...
Das müssten wir, das müssten wir echt mal machen.
Stream and stream, äh...
Dann Unity-Media flamestreamen.
Und wir Unity-Media auf Twitter vollspammen.
Aber, das, die Sache ist die...
Ähm...
Der Twitter-Support von Unity-Media gibt sich wirklich sehr viel Mühe.
Das ist die Falschen, die es trifft, wenn man sie, wenn man sie nervt.
Ja, ja, was spricht denn gegen so eine hier?
Die scheint mir doch ganz okay zu sein.
Oder meinetwegen auch sowas hier.
Das sieht halt noch ein bisschen billiger aus.
Die haben halt viel Ein-Stern-Bewertungen.
Die sagen, dass es ihnen Daten gibt.
Ja, wer weiß, was die Leute da immer treiben.
Also, ich hatte bisher mit dem Sharkoon-Ding noch keine Probleme.
Max Geht, der ist noch nicht wach.
Also, sollten die mich auf DSLite umstellen, werde ich sofort kündigen.
Und, ähm...
Dann gehe ich lieber wieder zur Telekom, weil DSLite ist einfach Bullshit.
Wäre es ja mittlerweile so, dass alles ohne Probleme mit IPv6 gut funktioniert,
und man überall IPv6-Anbindungen hat,
und auch auf dem Weg alles IPv6 ist,
hey, dann wäre alles in Ordnung.
Dann bräuchte ich auch keine IPv4 mehr, aber...
Ich gehe stark davon aus, dass wir nie vollständig IPv4 loswerden.
Nie.
Zumindest nicht zu unseren Lebzeiten.
Hatten wir schon?
Ja, das ist vom Stream gestern.
Da ging es um den Staubsauger.
Da muss ich jetzt nicht mehr viel erzählen.
Aber DSLite macht normalerweise heute keine mehr aus,
weil es ist nur für Multimedia.
Und wahrscheinlich Kabel Deutschland und alle anderen,
die zu wenig IPv4-Adressen haben.
Was ist denn der Vorteil von IPv6
außer größerem Adressraum?
Ja, hauptsächlich der größere Adressraum.
Und dass ein paar Sachen ganz gut durchdacht sind.
Zum Beispiel die automatische Adressvergabe
ist ganz gut durchdacht.
Du musst theoretisch, wenn du Rechner zusammenstöpselst,
gar keine IP-Adressen mehr vergeben.
Eigentlich brauchst du auch kein DHCP mehr.
NUT gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Also doch, das stimmt nicht.
NUT gibt es theoretisch noch,
aber macht mit der Anzahl der Adressen natürlich wenig Sinn.
Das war es glaube ich zum größten Teil.
Also das wichtigste ist auf jeden Fall,
dass es mehr Adressen gibt.
Ich muss euch ja ehrlich sagen,
so schön IPv6 ist,
von dem was es bringt,
ich glaube, dass IPv4
sich für interne Sachen
doch recht lang halten wird.
Einfach auch,
obwohl man IPv4...
Klar, es gibt DNS.
Eigentlich ist DNS die Antwort
darauf, dass man sich IP-Adressen nicht merken kann.
Und man kann IPv6-Adressen
gekürzt schreiben.
Aber es ist trotzdem viel einfacher,
sich IPv4-Adressen
zu merken, als
IPv6-Adressen.
Allerdings,
was auf jeden Fall sein wird,
dass in Zukunft
so ziemlich alles Dual-Stack hat.
Weil,
wenn man intern
IPv4 hat, kann man natürlich
logischerweise nicht
mit was externem kommunizieren,
was IPv6 hat.
Und auch nicht mit großartigem...
Das einzige vielleicht, wenn du irgendwie einen Proxy dazwischen hast oder so.
Aber zumindest nicht direkt.
Das bringt auch nichts,
wenn ein Router da irgendwelche Magic macht.
Umgedreht funktioniert es.
Umgedreht geht das.
Wenn du eine IPv6-Adresse hast
und intern eine IPv4-Adresse,
dann kannst du es mappen,
aber umgedreht geht es nicht.
Weil von außen nach innen ist klar,
da kannst du ganz fest diese IPv6-Adresse
auf diese internen IPv4-Adresse mappen.
Umgedreht funktioniert das Ganze nicht.
Du kannst ja nicht deine IPv4
für die restliche Welt irgendwie mappen.
Also willst du
IPv6 verwenden,
IPv6-Internet verwenden,
brauchst du selbst eine IPv6-Adresse.
Du kannst ja nicht irgendwie sehen,
wie viel Bandbreite andere Rechner
gerade im Netz nutzen.
Wenn dein Router das kann,
kannst du einfach gucken,
was da über die Ports drüber geht.
Oder an einem Switch.
Also du kannst nicht von deinem
du kannst nicht von deinem Rechner gucken,
was andere Rechner gerade für Bandbreite verwenden,
weil du siehst den Traffic von anderen Rechnern ja nicht.
Das ist ja gerade der Sinn von einem Switch.
Ja, SharksDevelopment,
das geht.
Wobei, so einfach ist das auch nicht.
So einfach ist das auch nicht.
Eingehend geht das,
ausgehend geht das nicht so ohne weiteres.
Du kannst zwar einen IPv4
einen IPv4 VPN aufbauen,
dann brauchst du darüber aber
auch auf beiden Seiten eine IPv6-Adresse,
die du dann quasi über diesen Tunnel
verpackt schickst.
Das ist dann quasi so ein bisschen
sowas wie Toolstack Lite.
Cisco oder HP-Switches,
da geht das auf jeden Fall.
Da siehst du, was für Bandbreite verbraucht wird.
Jeder halbwegs gescheite Router
oder Switch,
der ein bisschen besser ist,
der zum Beispiel auch irgendwie
entweder eine Management-Webinterface hat
oder eine Management-Kommandozeile hat,
hast du so einen Graph,
so einen Graph-Tab,
wo man sieht,
was da an Bandbreite verbraucht wird.
Was ist eigentlich dein Fazit zu Proxmox 6?
Ich fand das richtig gut.
Also mir hat das echt gut gefallen.
Wir haben es uns ja nur mal kurz angeguckt im Stream.
Wenn man Windows ME nicht richtig installieren lässt.
Ich fand es richtig gut.
Das Webinterface hat mir,
also für den Heimgebrauch,
das Webinterface hat mir gut gefallen.
Die Möglichkeiten, die man hat, hat mir gut gefallen.
ZFS 08 hat mir auch gut gefallen.
Mir hat das Rebooten gut gefallen.
Weißt du, ob es eine Fritzbox das kann?
Ich weiß es nicht,
ob eine Fritzbox Bandbreite-Nutzung anzeigen kann,
aber ich würde mal darauf tippen,
dass sie das kann.
Ich habe mir das noch nie angeguckt auf einer Fritzbox,
aber ich würde sagen,
man kann sich auch bei einer Fritzbox bestimmt angucken,
was die anderen Leute im Netzwerk für eine Bandbreite brauchen.
Eine Fritzbox kann das nicht, echt nicht.
Okay.
Meinst du, dass es sich lohnt,
von Proxmox 5 auf 6 zu gehen?
Kann ich nichts zu sagen,
weil ich, wie gesagt, schon ewig keinen Proxmox mehr verwendet habe
und jetzt einfach mal Testinstallation mit dem 6er gemacht habe.
So Leute, ich glaube, wir sind wach.
Zweieinhalb Stunden gestreamt heute Morgen.
Also ich bin zumindest wach,
auch wenn ich gerade gegähnt habe.
Ich werde jetzt mal gucken,
wird ja schon fast Zeit,
dass ich mir überlege, was ich mir heute zum Mittagessen mache.
Ähm,
ob da irgendjemand on ist, den man hosten kann.
Livestream C++.
Cute!
Cute-Stream.
Ey, 3D-Drucker ist immer noch on.
Ja, der Typ da hat die ganze Zeit.
Äh, Leute, ich gehe jetzt auf.
Vielleicht bin ich nachher nochmal on.
Mal gucken, wenn wir ein bisschen Technik-Grams machen nachher noch.
Ähm,
ich weiß bloß nicht genau,
was, also falls mir was Gutes einfällt heute
Mittag für ein Stream,
dann
machen wir nochmal ein Stream
und wir sehen uns bis denn. Macht's gut.
See you.